une production du studio sf bio sans
filtre présentée par chris miller
podcast où on parle lorsqu'on avec nos
invités date située à stein mois
d'hommes planquès me vient tout juste de
lancer leur deuxième collection estivale
avec des tout nouveau design que vous
pouvez voir si vous écoutez sur youtube
présentement puis une autre affaire qui
ont fait en fait c'est que vous pouvez
changer la couleur d'un même design donc
trouver la couleur qui vous représente
le plus à l'échec et leur nouvelle
collection sur leur site web puis tu es
encore trop molle sans filtre 20 khz
pour 20% de rabais
cette même dame seule sans fil cette
semaine on reçoit françois lambert qui a
été un des premiers invités ou tout
début qu'on reçoit une deuxième fois
vous le connaissez en tant
qu'entrepreneur en tant que dragon
attend que participa avec voix de 1 go
de plusieurs business et plusieurs
projets go
inspira cas qui parle d'entrepreneuriat
quand même et 50 travail en communauté
incroyable certains il peut être pas la
raison l'emporté prise de position mais
s'est calmé les différends sont quand
même et on le sent plus plus rassembleur
moins politisés plus rassemblement puis
on a parlé beaucoup de ces nouvelles
définissent des portes comme les
produits d'érable ce serait vraiment
super intéressant ce père de famille qui
parle et elle se fait que juste avant
d'aller écouter la conversation on va
les remercier nos commanditaires
le podcast est présenté par world aurait
eu lieu vous les connaissez une
commandite souvent ils font des produits
alimentaires pour chier les produits où
elle vend des produits hypoallergène
pour votre petit votre petit pitou qu'il
petit très petit chien ou un énorme et
colosses 2008 des produits hwa de 8 les
produits innovants des produits
hypoallergène fait à base de protéine
alternative des gâteries à base de
poudre de grillon abbas à bagdad de la
gaspésie à base de purées cycliques sont
peu utilisées pour faire du conflit
country avec ceux des produits
éco-responsables tissu parc où ils font
aussi de la nourriture à base d'insectes
de la nourriture à base de cartes
asiatique qui est en fait un poisson qui
doit être pêchés pour conserver les
fonds marins d'autres travaillent
conjointement avec des pêcheurs
nord-américain pour s'assurer d'avoir
des sources de protéines éco responsable
on a un code promo pour vous autres qui
le sf vang pour 20% de rabais si vous
allez sur leur site web
mon chien sauve le monde point ca avec
merci la gamme de ward rire puis
honnêtement à dire que c'est parce que à
chaque fois qu'on parle de lui et devant
qui nous disent qu'ils ont achetés soit
pour leur chien qui eux mais aussi le
chine allait voir ce petit merci à
gagnoa le seul le podcast de cette
semaine est aussi présentée par notre
page piquionne sur laquelle en ce moment
ou dans les prochains jours on va en
fait va se retrouver plusieurs podcast
qu'on a enregistrées en début de semaine
ont fait ce sont maintenant on essaie de
faire des petits blast d'enregistrement
pour pouvoir se libérer un petit peu
dans nos dans nos vies respectives fait
là il va avoir sur le sur le pétrole
dans les prochains jours il va avoir le
podcast avec kim lizotte avec yann
quatre chiots nés avec toulouse une
cellule avec les draps
j'avais lu david bourgeois ne devait que
dans les prochains jours ou si c'est pas
déjà de ça va être le est pas bon pas de
casque ont enregistré dans un petit bled
qui vous serez pas déçus puis souligne
d'encourager c'est sûr que john que ça
se passe ça fait vraiment une grande
différence
quelques dollars par mois aux autres
nous permet d conçu par le podcast est
de toujours s'améliorer y de mettre la
barre toujours plus yes fait que les
tchèques et sauf merci merci d'être là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
photo lecteur et aurait continué à
belgrade est encore là et j'aurais
continué s'il y avait à partir de la
journée 80 quand j'ai de gagner le
dernier challenge avec les cordes sûr
que c'était sur 80 dojo la journée 80
logis plus de l'amour penser j'ai pu
absorber la vigie protéger je peux
envoyer promener tout le monde je peux à
tout le monde et je m'emmerde ici ce
qu'on pouvait pas dire qu'on s'ennuie ça
n'existe pas c'est un mot tabou le deck
study tu t'ennuies t out
il ya deux journées 80 j'ai fait comme
ayo et moi j'ai dit à ma blonde je
partais pour une semaine lors je dis ça
fait trois mois je partis c'est sûr car
fait sa vie je t'avais avec un autre
pendant cinq heures
mon cerveau spin est seul à réellement
là je t'en aller voir big brother
j'écoute je capable d'être au fait on
joue au hockey
là j'ai eu mon dan mais ça a duré que
cinq heures après ce mois avant cela je
savais pas ce qu'était la vie à
l'extérieur je n'avais plus j'étais dans
ma vie dans ma mission
ma vie est elle a beau me lever le matin
près d'un café qu'est ce que tu arrêtes
de passer tout ce qui existe en dehors
ou qui continue par cette année cet
enfer en même temps moins nettement que
je ne sais pas trop ph quant à faire od
mais pour moi
levy extérieur n'existait pas seulement
c'est tellement mécanisme de de survie à
l'intérieur ne pas penser ce qui se
passe à l'extérieur parce que de toute
façon je le sais pas obligé pas de
contrôle fait moi je n'avais plus de vie
que ma compagne est bien ou mal
c'était bizarre mais c'est pas que ça
m'intéresse impôts mais je voulais à
chaque fois que j'avais une pensée pour
l'extérieur n'ont de toute façon je
repars réponse puis je vais m'ennuyer et
je vais pas m'ennuyer
j'aurais paniqué dans votre position
parce que moi j'ai trouvé ça long quand
j'étais à occupation double j'étais à
bali à l'extérieur tout le kit là dans
une maison mais je vouvoyais jeter la
crise il doit avoir rien à faire toute
l'énergie et la ferme et tu t'arranges
avec ce qui en fait il y en avait un jim
vraiment exceptionnel dans des
circonstances donc qu'est ce que je fais
mais je me levais tôt ben je voulais
courir une heure après sa belle avec
kate von finck qui voulaient s'entraîner
s'entraîner dès 2-3 heures l'après midi
syfy
non parce que moi j'ai besoin je me suis
entraîné mais je mange pas de coeur mon
envie presque peau mais la boîte poche
ouattara maintenant on ne peut pas
décider de tout revenu là les gens
veulent manger des pâtes un soir puis on
mangeait toujours en gagne pas dimanche
départ août fois que j'ai mangé pour mal
plus de câbles par monolith était très
habitué tout ton corps et non mais non
mon corps répond au besoin de manger des
cartes donc quand même je m'entraînais
beaucoup j'ai vu comme un débalancement
mais potel notamment partis avec un
match joué mettons première semaine que
tu prendrais jusqu'à la fin à tout parce
que non mais je savais que je sais que
contrairement à tout le monde
je le savais que le casting que j'avais
j'écoute tout à big brother à travers le
monde pour moi je savais de castet
pourquoi le je savais pourquoi qui me
castex et je le savais que si je ne
gagnais pas la première épreuve je
partais de la maison il me sacré les a
tout fait en partant c'est écrit dans le
ciel dans tout les big blue à travers le
monde les gens quant au casting comme
moi
se font éliminer mais là ce moment-là
tout du casting comme toi maintenant
cette offre quelques riches vieux que j
adore ce parce que son jus
étant donné qu'on n'était connue c'est
pas comme si on est des big bird canada
personne ne connaît il ya un mois
j'étais un cultivateur si je vais faire
big board of canada d'année prochaine
je suis un élevage ce que je suis navré
je dois over jouer mon casting
d'agriculteurs parce que les gens aiment
les agriculteurs jouent partout que je
les écoute là ces gens là ont la cote
fax et c'est exactement ce que je ferai
mais elle savait le casting puis je me
suis dit si je gagne pas je reviens mais
j'avais dit à ma gamme puis dans mon
entreprise mais ils voulaient pas me
revoir avant au moins un mois être non
plus d'avoir la paix a gagné le j'ai
fait comme ailleurs je peux me faufiler
père m'a donné
ipic avec le casting que j'avais fallait
que je gagne des épreuves que je le dis
moi je vais tout vous battre toutes les
épreuves et ski c'est ce qui me sourit
parce que avec le recul ce que j'ai
entendu c'est qu'ils n'avaient pas de
mettre en danger parce qu'ils savaient
que s'ils mettent en danger
je pouvais aller gagner l'épreuve au
veto puis partira pas au mac il y avait
tellement pas de mettre en danger qui
m'ont jamais mis en fonctionnement
danger puissant vos pots on est cuit
fait que ça me protège et un bon après
ça c'était la game social tout à total
qui me sauver mes shows prix j'ai juste
eu un moment on pensait peut-être une
shot a regagné gagner ou tu savais que
peu importe le genre homo n'importe qui
j'ai cru en mes chances pour longtemps
à deux semaines de la fin quand j'ai
gagné le dernier veto j'ai fait j'ai
paca est une chance mais sauf que le
jury qui étaient les membres la maison
normalement sont séquestrés et ceux qui
votent pour le gone y n'ont pas vu les
émissions donc je savais très bien que
les premières semaines
si j'ai sorti geneviève d'une façon les
gens vont très cavalière moi je veux
dire extrêmement tactique je savais que
mes chances étaient pas tellement grand
que je pensais sincèrement que kim avait
des chances de gagner
all the wig pas ce qui était drôle cette
fille là bas le alain humour un peu que
tu peux pas montré télévision maintenant
était drôle pour tout le monde qui était
là mais non plus ont vu leurs
confessions les confessionnaux de kim
que moi je n'ai pas vu puis à 20 quand
j'ai vu ça après ça j'ai chargé mon
genre et d une chance j'aurais pu gagner
contre kim
quand j'entends moi je savais que je
perdais je savais que j'avais pas grand
chance et mais j'ai cru après avoir
gagné mon élevé tout j'ai fait j'ai pac
ait des chances et il fallait que kim
gagnent à dernière épreuve donc le
mandat n'est elle pas gagné et j'entends
monument de garde
on sent même point final parce qu'on
voulait passer la dernière semaine sans
se gausser je t'amène dessus tu
m'emmènes subi jouer de la games de
stratégie que ça nous tentait plus de
jouer ça mais quand en plus de jouer une
game niveau et facultés hausse et je
savais les gens osent y ait eu manger
une folie 12 0 enfin met en danger
j'ai pas moi je ne pollue les gens il ya
des gens qui ont voté contre moi
ce c'est bien évident bien des gens qui
ont voté pour jean thomas n'ayant pas
oublié des gens qui auraient voulu dans
l'autre et j'ai pilé lisant ou sont
venus chez nous je laisse même penser
mais on n'est pas en guerre lyon voté
contre moi
puis c'est mes amis je le savais que
j'avais ma chance
j'entame en a fait une belle game puis
honnêtement moi je m'arrange car je sais
ce que c'est on s'entend que l'incitatif
afin de gagner c'est pas la fin du monde
prie le typage pas démesurée dont le
prestige le prestige puis tout le monde
le sait qu on était rémunéré là bas
personne personne est sortie perdant
annoncé ça c'est sûr chaque semaine
supplémentaire considérable wapiti on a
tous quelque chose à vendre c'est tout
des gens qui ont soit une carrière à
refaire j'encadre but scientifique est
partout en ce moment arrêtée au baroque
est partout jean thomas qui est booké
mois nettement je veux je ne peux jeune
compagne en ligne les ventes sur le
tapis on nous dit ça ouvre des portes à
tout le monde non plus longtemps tue
resta télévision plus de visibilité à
l'augmenter c'était seul vrai prix le
dans notre commune puis toi d'aller là
c'était quoi la décision s'était dessus
par rapport à justement ce d'avoir
quelque chose à vendre le doigt et je
veux aller chercher de l'exposition pour
l'expérience de citer c'était quoi le le
raisonnement quelqu'un qui je suppose
ide ont appelé au mic a accepté de faire
ce bain ils m'ont appelé au mois de juin
l'année passée puis je reçois un appel
d'entourage vous qui était la maison de
production puis john ne projette parler
pour bell bell venait d'acheter
vaiedelich c'est marilyn ma blonde j'ai
fait comme elle sait le faune y est
peut-être qu'ils veulent mais vite et où
nouvelle était avec un beau projet du
moins d'après ammar est un site web sso
tu connais big brother sous et bat on
aimerait ce que tu viens du fait qu'un
mort tabarnouche si j'ai eu une petite
déception que j'ai fait comme mais
pourquoi t'es pas content tu les écoutes
toutes ces émissions l'autre sur live
voici et j'ai plongé puis mais sauf que
le danger personne ne veut partir du
premier le dentier dit situerait selon
temps tu peux partir la tête haute
mais si tu pars le premier but je savais
que je devais partir le premier je
savais ce qui m'attendait dans cette
émission là donc j'avais à xian de
vouloir elle est là pour m'aider à faire
progresser ma compagnie inhalent font la
nuit
ses seules lui nuire parce que c'est
cela c'est plus toi te la compagnie
aussi d'horreur où il ya 25 employés
maintenant c'est plus juste une start up
l'océan du bd des gros investissements
qu'on fait mais c'est adeline amusé
honnêtement d'alema musée c'est sûr que
que les gens boivent
quatre heures par jour sous mon vrai
jour je me suis dit bah ils vont bien
voir que je peux aussi est un personnage
qui montre dans l'est à la télé ou dans
les 12 mois qui est l'image que les
recteurs parce que c'est vraiment ce que
je trouve qu'il l'ait fixa le eu du
moins de ta participation celle ci on le
sait que il ya du monde qui avait une
certaine perception de toi de françois
lambert polémiste ici et si finalement
on a vu un gars gentil sensible
compétitif métier quand même je cours
beaucoup gagné en sympathie je parle
pour beaucoup de monde oui mais je le
vois je le vois puis tu es j'écris
peut-être distec ce qu'ils ont fait les
des controverses qui en fait vraiment ça
fait plus 2012 que j'écris des textes
sur facebook on était des crédits 10
mais ceci dit cela plus grand que nature
que les gens ont pensé que je toujours
un chercheur de troubles alors que j'en
suis pour un jeu revient au texte sur
les infirmières qui se voulait une truc
contre le syndicaux qui étaient mal lu
et que fait la polémique a même une
infirmière qui était suspendu qui a
perdu sa job à cause des menaces qu'elle
me fait ben oui ils savaient pas ce sens
qu'elle écrit mais this j'écris
peut-être juste même pas dit ce texte
il y en a qui ont pas de chez solide
parce que je suis je rentrais sur les
syndicats ou les gens de la construction
il se ça a été plus grand que nature
mais je pars gauche cherche la
controverse a envie moi d'être mal le
matin je me lève à 3h30 4h du matin soit
je m'entraîne et je les nouvelles une
vie bête l'abattra qu'il ai je pas le
goff flamboyant que les gens pensent que
je suit les fois que des controverses
est ce que est ce que c'est l'effet que
tu recherchais tous est surpris que ça
crée une mousse grosse controverse
maintenant je mets toujours pris en main
jamais jamais géré un texte en un seul
lot vaut pas de chez eux
vos points de chez je l'écris parce que
l'union est un sujet qui m'interpelle je
l'écris puis dans le cas des infirmières
sincèrement j'étais au chalet je
m'engage je répondais de natation le
bassin d'entraînement seul au chalet
puis je lis nouvelle j'avais le goût
d'écrire quelque chose je trouvais rien
que je vois que les infirmiers demandent
21 points 6 % d'augmentation et j'ai
pourquoi 21.6 puis j'ai juste doublé
21.6 s'adonne l'espace cubes d'un
frigidaire le frigidaire conventionnelle
d'une porte de 30 pouces c'est 20h06
fait que j'avais fait
je revenais sur mon fameux sujet des
pistes relation avec un spi as j'écris
un texte par rapport à sochaux 2-2
larmes que j'ai donnée jeudi d'après moi
le représentant syndical il revenait que
son épicerie
ça rentre pas dans son frigidaire piano
googler c'était juste une blague avait
le ski et ski pendant ce moment les
critiques sur l'augmentation je suis en
fait que ses 21 points 6 puis un chiffre
qui quand même pas que je trouvais en
utilisant des algues ou glace à monsieur
courbis un frigo dans un mais livre je
parle du test du frigo je n'ai décret
dont il y avait beaucoup de bien dans ma
tête mais ça peut aussi que les gens
pour s'assurer que les gens sont
capables de soulever de vitry je me suis
trouvé vraiment drôle juste aller nager
en revenant je regarde mon iphone j'ai
fait comme k6 pas aux puits encore
aujourd'hui je trouve encore drôle ce
texte met donc non je n'ai jamais
cherché la controverse
à part si j'interpelle quelqu'un s'est
enlevé une ou deux fois que j'ai
interpellé quelqu'un il ya c'est sûr que
c'est interpelle quelqu'un directement
tu cherches la contrebasse donc mais tu
es désir d'être plus consensuel qu'avant
et on habite depuis big brother ou dead
2 - provoqué où vous seriez que change
vraiment ben non c'est fait depuis la
pandémie dans le fond début de la
pandémie c'est que j'ai décidé de faire
plus de vidéos que de textes et avec les
vidéos c'est tout le temps d'expliquer
les gens peuvent voir ton sarcastique un
sourire faits peuvent voir que c'est une
blague que tu fais pipi les gens
finissent par de comprendre un peu plus
et il le fait faire des vidéos
a été changé beaucoup la perception des
gens et c'est pas mal plus fort de faire
une vidéo pour était tard expliqué fait
état d' expliquer ton idée puis de 10 et
puis j'ai presque plus de controverses
depuis ce temps là je veux qu'on parle
de ce jeu qu'on retourne un peu en
arrière ce que la dernière fois que tu
sais c'est qu'on dise ça fait trois ans
qu'ils manquent que tu es venu je suis
pas castrés puis deux puis je sais pas
si tu avais déjà lancé sa nouvelle
entreprise suscite à le lancer suite à
ton passage mais
mais ça existait pas le temps lol je
pense pour ben nantes avait déjà jeté
mon siro l'acheter après je l'achetais
après je l'aï achetée par ce que j'ai vu
parce que j'ai commencé à suivre
oui un peu avant qu'on compte reçoivent
peu après ce joli conte nature le gvuc
araneda tv du sirop bodyboard et ramos
était le beurre d'érable le ce que je
voulais absolument des faits que je
l'avais acheté après fais ce qui te
lancer ce jeu me liste des premiers
produits que tu lances et web et c'est
la façon que c'est la plupart du temps
lorsqu'une entreprise démarre t puis je
savais je partais d'entreprise alors que
je controversé juste personnes vont
acheter une sirop d'érable de françois
lambert parce que j'ai commencé à
l'avant du sirop d'érable pourquoi parce
que j'ai pas de coton puis je peux pas
vendre dans les magasins et moi j'ai
1000 gallons de sirop d'érable en
entrepôt que je sais pas quoi faire avec
spock me mettre sur le bord du chemin
puis comment la règle puis je vends une
canne abus pia cela n'a pas de sens
beaucoup de nouveaux magasins parce que
ça prend un coteau droit de produire 2
et ce droit de produire l'autre dans le
droit de le vendre c'est un peu complexe
de sirop d'érable au québec mais pour te
faire une image très simple un goût du
vermont peuvent venir vendre une canne
de sirop à mon dépanneur du coin sans
payer de frais il ya le droit moi
j'habite à côté du dépanneur je peux
être à porte à côté je vais pour mettre
ma canne j'ai pas le droit
faut que je paye un droit de le vendre
parce que je serais au québec c'est
aussi bizarre que cela est bon au
champagne avec cuba blond la du monde
devrait le vendre en ligne jusqu'ici que
va acheter du sirop ça pèse une tonne
on y reviendra parce que chaque trophée
louis ii
on commence et sa part en fou mais
littéralement si le 18e le 12 décembre
qu'on a commencé 2018 fox espère qu'on a
commencé
ok donc sa partie vraiment fou plage de
berck autres jeux de machines à bas on
voit offrir du bar sa part en fout
jrockit barrages et des lives on va en
profiter on va vendre les mets mes
livres aussi comme ce jeu vous faut les
dédicaces et cabano le premier week-end
je pense j'ai signé des livres le
week-end vip il n'arrêtait plus ce que
c'est que le monde il savait pas que tu
avais des livres mettant le monde qui te
suivent elles qui ont dit qu'ils le
jouent c'est le sirop comprend que
c'était quelque chose te ferai pas déjà
20 le beurre d'érable non plus mais le
lait livré qu'en ligne
c'est ce genre dépend directement de ta
plateforme pénale parce que t'es juste à
ma blonde jusqu'à citer gatti on fait
quoi avec sortie belge ici rien à faire
paître en prélevant dans ligne ça
marchera pour toutes avait des detroit
pistons lives chez vous qui traîne non
j'en ai demandé jeudi que le long
marathon et d'histoire ben ouais je les
écoute par boisemont voir ça marche et
ça a marché
et moi j'avais une machine après ça ça
déboule et les gens nous ont demandé du
sud parce qu'ils s'en aillent en france
où on a fait du super hab
il m'a donné quelques uns des titres cap
a fait la barbe à l'érable gijoe bout tu
as assez bon bah oui j'ai une machine
industrielle chez nous je veux tu
raconte l'histoire de cette machine de
barbe à papa le passé le pote bon 5e
temps et ce chiffre mais là ça passe ans
c'est moche et trop décidé mais type
ferry le montage sans vis moi je me lève
puis je m'amuse et je vais essayer avec
une petite machine pour faire la barbe à
papa l'érable puis ça marche à pau
fascise ok moi on achetait une vraie fin
que je le sais bien avant c'était même
pas un projet d'entreprise c'est un
projet phare et le monde je veux de la
barbe à papa à l'érable dit je goûte au
restaurant et j'achète une machine
industrielle qui est caché par toutes
les fois que quelqu'un venez chez nous
au chalet sans la barbe c'est parti les
taureaux de ceux qui ont fait ça sape il
partait panier je m'entraîne des enfants
mais c'est ça j'ai des amis qui sont nus
je prends un vidéo puis des fois on ne
sait jamais vers où ça va nous amener un
esprit vidéo puis j'ai dit s'il partait
on fait la barbe à papa l'érable le
monde du dead to man faire bagis non jeu
donc on met ça dans quoi elle m'a pas ça
dans un sac pour le chp et ont retrouvé
des po puis elle m'a donné mais là c'est
devenu immense le savoir faire lol a
cessé ses rangs d'une méga entre bandes
du dragon le web etc puis tout le monde
m'appelle l'ex dragon fait je commençais
à plessala la barbe de dragon le sort de
dragon la lame de dragon puis c'est
devenu à branne sans le vouloir
et bien si ça fait deux ans et demi
maintenant on produit en moyenne en deux
et quatre mille peut-être dépendamment
de journée l'an 2 et 4 mais le pape par
jour qu'on qu'on distribue qu'on
distribue
tribu et en deux et quatre mille barbe
par jour mais il se vend dans rieter
maintenance pendant huit heures il va
beaucoup en ligne on vient d'envoyer
notre première palette en corée du sud
de barbe à papa
je ne sais pas comment que la personne
de connu métier c'est en ayant une
présence forte sur les réseaux sociaux
en répétant le message constamment il ya
peut-être quelqu'un du québec qui a
parlé de moi quelqu'un toronto qui fait
de l'exportation en corée du sud et de
filets nous envoyer un e-mail
pouvez vous nous envoyez des produits
puis les les passions d'un match
plaisant
on a reçu une demande du nigeria puis le
mondial c'est de la fraude lui quoi moi
quand j'ai l'argent dans mon compte de
banque
ce constat que c'est plus de la france
et donc ça n'était on ne pas embarquer
dans le bateau avait fait que j'ai dit
pis la marilyn reçoit pau nakhcha big
brother à la swan demande d'avoir des
produits d'érable
c'est d'avoir un fracas l'envoi la liste
de nos produits pis les gens disent ben
écoute on va prendre la barbe pas qu'on
va en prendre quatre mille a du bon ok
parfait
la semaine passée il ya deux semaines
dibona l'argent dans le compte
puis la palette est parti hier matin par
toronto à 120 corée du sud sera pas bon
c'est facile des fois tu fous faut
jamais tu dis donc tu réponds aux gens
comme si c'était ben correct et il donne
une demande faite à ça j'en ai parlé ces
réseaux sociaux petit les gens ils ont
peur d'en parler et j'en parle me
réveiller un compétiteur et moche m'en
fous en vue de la compétition et l'oeil
de dubaï qui nous demande d'en avoir des
palettes aussi donc on va voir son
sérieux aussi mais tout ça est parti
pour fair et le mans sera pas bon je le
ferai parce qu'elle écoute sa machine
qui est grosse comme ça et
ces bons n'ont pas vu le jeu sait pas
s'il écoute en largeur des bras et ici
c'est comme ça c'est parti c'est drôle
parce que tu quand tu étais venu tout à
vous raconter ton parcours
d'entrepreneur petit qui était un peu
tombé sur les centres d'appels un peu
par hasard dans forrest et des au début
c'était pour le fun ou cette épopée
finalement c'est devenu une business
mais ben la plupart des entreprises
tille ce que cherche trop une entreprise
finissent par nos peaux se lancer si
souvent dans notre façon et on le tout
le temps côté de nos pions le refuse
moi j'étais bien laval me lancer dans
cette entreprise lol j'ai une belle vie
c'est ça tu avais pas besoin de
travailler encore pour le résultat ville
non mais tu en es tu manques de
challenges ton cerveau tout ça qui a pas
de défi il ce côté là du défi m'ennuyais
de promouvoir un monde plein mais si tu
es rendu une autre entreprise c'est pas
seulement mes produits la vitrine
québécoise on est presque 500 produits
de nouveau des entrepreneurs du québec
ça marche à fond appeler un plein régime
et là on est dans les chandelles on a
deux les savons au lait de brebis
on rend à peu près partout dans lé 8
elle s'est rendue une meilleure
entreprise le cgdd 25 25 employés
directs mais 25 employés y travaillent
h oui sans compter que je travaille
qu'une boîte de marketing pour tout le
packaging sont certes on travaille à
temps plein pour nous autres là dessus à
temps plein je puis on fait d une gamme
de produits à l'eau d'érable
c'est pour moi qu'il fait donc
j'embauche un labo pour qu'il fasse pas
ce que je peux pour m'équiper dans tout
ça qu'on fait des crèmes à l'eau
d'érable
dans un labo donc sont trois temps plein
quand on regarde juste didier direct on
fait travailler peut-être déjà 45
personnes sans compter toutes les
entrepreneurs qu'on représente
ghalioun qui est passé aux dragons
marisol les paye là maïs marisol détail
la whey cdd paloc du peu mais quand tu
prépares mais son mélange est tellement
bon mot georges ça fait je mange pas de
club parce que j'en parle parce que je
capote pas c'est bon un écoute ça rentre
chez nous appelle et on en manque tout
le temps tout le temps tu autant tout le
temps donc je suis différent non mais
c'est le sait sur l'enfant c'est des
gâteaux aux fruits avant noël je pense
qu'il le goff venez nous porter une
vente à tout les jours c'est le temps
des fêtes ça qu'on crée de l'emploi à
travers le québec c'était pas prévu mais
j'ai du fun à faire ce métier c'était
pas prévu
maintenant c'est prévu parce que l'on
lance un paquet de nouveaux produits est
il assez devenait bran sans vouloir être
bran parce que je l'avais jamais appelé
si c'était planifié je l'aurais pas
blement je leur ai parlé françois
labarre moi c'est juste c'est la raison
pourquoi françois lambert c'est que
marilyn a été ma blonde je les
rencontrais dans une réunion et après un
mois bâtisse gage pour elle est aidée
par je tenterai d'écrire un livre que
j'ai très peu d organiser des fois puis
je prenais mon temps puis le l'éditeur
me poussant derrière je prédis td puis
j'avais beaucoup de demandes de
conférences que je répondais jamais fait
pas je te voir tom gerber des
conférences mal préparés faca titre avec
toi pour vol france a bloqué 2 j'ai
perdu là bas
bah oui faites lundi baisse après
l'adresse email sont pas vraiment
professionnel gmail ben on regarde puis
françois lambert points comme coincé
dans toutes les rues puis la veille sur
go daddy point au moins deux fenêtres de
tous vers le
le suffixe point one on le prie jeu ça
va faire rire le monde encore vont
penser que je me prends pour deux
saisons événement est scellé pour avoir
un adresse e-mail à ma blonde et
finalement c'est devenu à branne que je
maintenant je peux plus je peux plus
changé c'est fou ça me fait capoter puis
le quand il ya eu la pandémie car
pandémie a frappé parce que quand il ya
eu le premier confinement moi je
t'écoute est quotidiennement j'écoutais
s'était jetée en prenant votre café le
matin
oui puis le soir tu faisais diffuser ça
s'appelait pas encore en prenant votre
vernis ans et s'appelle derrière le
contrôle derrière le comptoir c'est
exact puisque dans le fond toi qu'un la
pandémie a frappé le temps une boutique
en ligne qui existe déjà
oui sauf que là on se rend compte que
collectivement que le commerce en ligne
c'est la façon de faire
oui parce que parce que tu es moi je les
ai vécus à gris on ne peut plus être je
suis plus dans l'entreprise sauf que 15
ans à tomber
ça s'est vendu en ligne ça n'avait pas
de bon sens et puis comment est ce que
j'imagine qu'à une énorme croissance
quand c'est arrivé rapidement qu'il ya
des défis logistiques insurmontable
heureusement lundi non mais la beauté
c'est que l'entreprise existait déjà
depuis 18 mois et c'est souvent
d'entreprises sap en à peu près 18 à 24
mois mais de trouver ses repères api
gérer le shipping parce que le shopping
était problématique mais on était la
croisée des chemins parce que je faisais
les produits en campagne jamais touchant
montréal et mon sous-sol à montréal qui
mon garage était que ce soit dans mes
dont c'étaient des produits partout
partout partout qu'intervilles la
pandémie on dit au hockey il faut
déménager son de tout parti si loin
camion on est parti en campagne et on
avait déjà la logistique plein les
entrepreneurs m'appeler moi mais je sais
pas comment vendre jamais goûté produire
une montée de produits et on est passé
de béton 50 connu par jour à 500 ans
quand même table en 48 heures et en même
temps c'est parce que c'était la saison
des sucres les gens m'associent à
l'érable donc c'est en même temps et on
travaille on n'a pas
aff on trouvait pas de thé comble f1 au
début on était juste mais relais de moi
mon frère qui venait m'aider bleeps
remédié à temps plein parce qu'il était
professeur puis s'est arrêté un masseur
qui venait mais d'un petit peu le pied
500 colis je suis à travailler 24 heures
par jour déjà plus graves
gross a perdu du poids ce lait dans des
tentes était vraiment mal prend tout le
monde et ça pcu en plus le bord fait que
serveur et c'était extrêmement difficile
à trouver des gens au début
mannone mais il ya quelqu'un qui est
venu puis mon frère vit et travaille à
ma soeur aussi puis on a réussi à s'en
sortir a trouvé un employé pin up un
autre puis ça a explosé comme ça mais on
a lâché on a high et même livre à moi
chenal fond de rade en campagne mais
vraiment la ctu près les péripéties que
tu racontais avec les différentes du
bord le stuff qui est obligée de bloquer
le chemin pas qu'ils partent
il est arrivé chez nous qui dit il ya
trop de conneries je prends pas ça non
mais je dis jeta averti cas pour m'avoir
beaucoup mais tu peux pas prendre ça il
dit c'était bien trop gros pour moi mon
problème
on est dans une impasse l'église belge
est propos j'ai oublié surf samassa g
dessus bloque le chemin j'ai pris le
coincer il se prend date a mis la dame
beau justin avant son émission prend en
otage la police appelle la police je te
prends pas notre job c'est de ramasser
des colis et finalement les aux prix ils
s'approprient les a pas faites moi
j'avais une vanne les judokates pas vrai
que je veux laisser tomber
5 ça y est notes de cette fois que je
passe n'est même plus que cela le savez
pas de sens j'ai rempli ma vanne au
complet on est monté au dépôt à montréal
aller les porter et après c'est la
compagnie me contacter le président à
toronto steady comme quand j'avais eu un
problème avec il m'a contacté puis
depuis ce temps alors j'ai pu aucun
problème mais se sont adaptés shipping
et a rappelé son exclusive sur t'excuser
voyage ne sera pas sans moi je te donne
la bns sur refuse la prendre a été rendu
un blues s'est rendu chez nous le
terrain depuis je vais t'aider à l'eau
des faits piégés dimanche sa rando je
remette la balance dans mon camion puis
je vais aller de jaude suivent ils
voulaient pas il tenta pas de travailler
cette journée là mais si des défis comme
ça que fait comment quand les épuisants
métier si c'est les gens sont surpris
les livres à ce parce que tu as
ricciardo toro de chez nous tu prennes
grande route tu prends de monter supra
ok il était dans le fond le plus immense
importance qu est ce qui se passe ils
savent que je vais chercher son colis
si c'était un transporteur fait que
mais bon c'est comme ça c'est s'aider
défi mais tu t'adaptes tu t'adaptes puis
regarde juste imprimer les shopping les
boules départ soit une commande de brin
de shopping et bob avant noël fallait un
premier en ont travaillé deux personnes
à temps plein toute la journée
10 12 heures par jour brin prime un
shopping de bons plans des coûts de sa
puissance faut encore changé on a changé
de fournisseur mais toutes sortes de
petits défis comme ça que les gens se
rendent pas compte
on recevait tellement de commandes
confond nice et pau a imprimé les
shopping mall pour les envoyer c'est le
plus gros défi autre continent autre
depuis que le studio petit con compte
qu'on ne tourne et se disent notamment
c'est comment rendre les choses de plus
efficace possible c'est seulement à
chaque jour sa question qu'on se pose
comment on peut rendre plus efficace
parce que amenés de tout faire - soi
même c'est impossible
non mais c'est sûr photo they come on
vendait beaucoup les pop corn en pot le
maintenant acheter une machine une
machine pour ensacher pour aller encore
plus rapide
dites-donc photo jour automatisée et à
chaque fois que je vais maintenant dans
l' usine pas ce qui est en construction
chaque fois que je viens la fin de
semaine il ya quelque chose de changer
pour changer la la mécanique pour que ce
soit plus autonomes à chaque fois que tu
es des nouveaux défis comme le j'avais
un seul camion mon livre beaucoup dans
les neziri là on arrive l'autre jour
pour aller livrer dans une grande
bannière dans mon camion recul il pas
d'autres beaux ils parent auteur de des
docks
on n'accepte pas qu'on voit loin camions
ont fait pas attention aux banques coûte
une porte ont fait pas attention qui est
pas des cow boys sont présentes encore
n'ont qu'à lyon repris plus de plus plus
haut que l'autre je me suis tanné c'est
tellement de perte d'argent 1 que rob de
temps à perdre de temps fait l'objet
d'un camion avec des paiements des
fautes parce que si je suis à montréal
je n'ai pas ce problème là je peux
prendre un camion au coin de la rue et
il le loue et puis allez leur
porte-monnaie moi j'habite à 100 km 150
km du premier location de camions donc
juste prendre le camion qui est un clan
straw faut que j'envoie un chauffeur qui
qualifiait pour aller chercher ces 50
yens à l'impressionner quinzaine de
kilomètres avait pas de sens
enfin jusseau faut que j'achète un
camion près de kaboul pour être dans
l'est dans les grands centres de
distribution
les grands centres de distribution il
faut se rendre dans leurs systèmes vécu
c'est un cauchemar
faut que tu arrives une fois on arrive
pour livrer pas de palette bleue nous
refuse un paquet de défauts
après six mois d'avant avec des erreurs
ça coûte cher et d'assez ne pas faire
trop d'erreurs
régulièrement nous apprend plus vite et
assez de monétiser des erreurs comme
quoi bergame qu'est ce qui peut donner
un exemple de superga jal est un exemple
concret en ce moment dans la commande de
corée du sud y compris n'ont pas fait
attention et après c'est un lion prix
des peaux prend le dessus parle de la
gagne à la luzerne de chez vous et ce
soir ils étaient pressés fait qu'ils
n'ont pas fait attention et ont pour une
boîte de pau qui marquent et sauf de
dragons et ont pris le couvercle barbe
de dragons et ils ont mis la barre de la
daille nos 1500 peau dans les mauvais
points lebon couverte les mauvais pau
fête le dimanche sont rentrés qu'en qui
sont rendus compte de ce samedi après
midi en préparant la palette qui s'est
en allé labo bail en fait comme vous ce
qu'est ce que je fais que mes seins sans
projet jette mais j'ai fait un post
facebook plus du bea regarde
profitez-en gars je vous en donne deux
par toutes les commandes donc chaque
langue que vous allez faire j'en
commande que vous allez faire je donne
deux points gâchent pas pour rien faire
avec poetry
puis j'ai vendu énormément donc les gens
qui hésitaient des fois les gens ont
besoin d'un petit coup de pouce pour se
convaincre de venir acheter parce qu'ils
trouvent un compte il est plus dur dans
les commerces en ligne pour le client
plus j'en fais partie en ont fusé move
encore un autre compte rentrer mais un
fou donc faut les convaincre de faire
saut et écoulant alors donné un cadeau
que de toute façon mon champagne avec je
vois les jeter je veux trouver une
solution mais ces gens là viennent parce
qu'ils y ont eu un cadeau qui va tu vois
pas de ready cash tout le monde aime les
cadeaux enfin que
le concrétiser on ne rien gaspiller
finalement dans leur portée de notre
façon donc sinon j'ai une perte
monumentale ces bretons de ma commande
de corée du sud
le profit est passé par une gaffe
majeure on l'a tourné en opportunité que
moi c'est une façon d'appuyer cette
release
si oui qu'est ce que tu penses qui a été
c'est parce que des personnes qui
veulent se sortir en entrepreneuriat il
y en a plein de 5 pi rares sont les gens
qui voient capable de s'enchaîner les
sucs site c'est le taux d'échec est pas
mal plus grand que le taux de succès
maintenant ce que qu'est-ce qui est
qu'est ce que tu penses que toi te qui
fait que ça fonctionne t enchaîne de
mangue je me décourage jamais je suis
jamais découragé par un obstacle pour
moi un obstacle ça fait partie je me
sens que je vais te frappe un mur baisse
parce que c'était pas le bon chemin
selon mme el habiri je m'en bas côté à
gauche marché à gauche mais en bas à
droite
y'a rien qui me découragement absolument
absolument rien je me dis bon c'est
comme honnêtement comme cette situation
la demande sur tous les courages et ma
soeur rose pour me le disait pas c'est
elle qui a fait la gaffe
marilena dit bon on va avoir encore des
pertes hommage même pas penser puisqu'il
faut trouver une solution avec ça moi
j'ai toujours une solution
je me décourage pas médicaux honnêtement
ça arrive jamais que je suis découragé à
mettons ça arrive jamais tu vois quelque
chose parce que ça m'arrive quand même
ça me décourager mais ça m'arrive
souvent argent il ya quand même c'est la
merde c sauf que tout bois sur pied au
sto cks à nantes on trouve une en trouve
une solution
oui en mode solution de ce jeu toujours
en mode solution jld page privée
jovialiste là il ya des fois je me dis
oh non mais quand je regarde chez le fai
peau si je fais pas ça ben oui je veux
que ça soit être payant oui je veux que
ça soit 1 mondial cette entreprise l'ont
été l'autre jour une coque et une cabane
à sucre qui me copie surtout tout ce que
je fais il ya peu à peu près les mêmes
statuts en faisant des fautes en essonne
intégralement des 18 mètres plus loin de
toi j y ai locale
ok il yad'autres fait ce qu'il veut je
m'en fous mais quelqu'un d'autre face la
pop du pape prennent à l'érable pitts y
en a plusieurs qui le font bien il le
monde m'a dit ils vont en acheter un peu
de plus et ça va être plus qu'on ne
saurait plus connus moi j'ai pas de
problème mais moi je pense mondial je
veux poète local je veux que le québec
rayonne à travers
je veux que ma région la piste nation
qui dans le dow est soit vu à travers le
monde donc ce qu'on a fait on a fait un
clin d'oeil à chicago mixé par contre
j'suis comme ils sont la plaie le mec la
petite nation et c'est un mélange de pop
corn au bar à l'érable et puis histoire
est totale pour moi j'arrive dans un
aéroport à londres voi le mec
obstination comme la même chose qu'on
achète le chicago mix ici donc moi les
petits obstacles que j'ai comme ça je me
dis non pas une vision mondiale moi j'ai
tout le temps
si tout le temps soit que je disais ce
que je vais atteindre ce que je veux je
sais pas si je me fais chier avec un
livreur dit comme un après midi ici
alors que j'ai juste 500 boîtes des jeux
sans guillemets 500 boîtes qui parle
comment je peux penser à dans un
aéroport allons maintenant si ce moment
le type ans peser la menace c'est un
petit tacle minimes dans l'objectif
global
oui c'est pas nécessaire d'avoir un
obstacle comme ça mais ça fait partie
mois les cas les gens du courage un
épisode locarno va le faire on voit
d'ailleurs on va les faire si ça ne
commence à faire des chandelles peau des
chandelles et l'érable t il la montre de
60 la cabane chez vous le bruit fait que
l'on n'a rien fait et total mais là on
est en train de siffler une joke le
business des baies des chandelles on
vise à voir sa chandelle d'ici noël en
sorte de chambre s'en sorte de
chandelles on les signaux qui fait en ce
moment il ya deux personnes à temps
plein qui travaillent à temps plein du
maton trois quarts des chandelles et il
avec les saints on vise probablement
d'avoir 10 15 personnes encore l'autre
objet de s'équiper de nouveaux
équipements à chaque semaine presque
mets typiques hommage grandi cette
entreprise là mais je regarde qu'est-ce
qui les gens aiment
qu'est ce que t'es mettons sur amazon la
chandelle la plus vendu sur amazon
c'est pas évident donc à nadeau à
grandes feuilles
on a six de trouver la faille en sont la
parfaite chablais la bouche bitume en
ferrain m'a fabriqué ils ont fabriqué
fait l'on s'en vient avec cette
chandelle aussi c'est comme ça qu'une
entreprise qui fonctionne pas je peux
pas faire une entreprise en voulant
faire vendre des produits à toi tu dois
t'adapter moi les gens le trim dit au
québec a fait une chandelle à l'érable
parfait faute en fait réussi ou ses
avocats ni faire à terme soit parfait
pour autant faire une à l'avant en même
temps vos plantes et de la lavande
donc moi c'est tout le talent de la
terre à vous on utilise de l'huile de
soya de cire de soyaux donc c'est
l'appât l'érable donc faut tout le temps
que je me rapproche déterminer si les
gens qui dictent mois dans l'entreprise
la plus moi qui donne la direction
je vends avec en direction que l'iq liam
a même dû simplement on va demander de
faire des pas pour me protéger je
m'envoie dans le point de protéines et
on me demande de faire si et si je vois
que je ne peux tu n'étais je laissais
mais moi en ce moment la compagnie n'est
plus tellement ma vision là je ramasse
les informations que j'ai et je m'enlève
dans des directions pigeât cei mais
comment tu fais pour aussi bien sont des
dons quand on un jour de rage des gens
et c'est là que les réseaux sociaux font
la grosse dalle 10 pour ça que je me
lève le manège fait vidéo de matin j'ai
enfin autre le soir des fois je m'en
faire le jour dit mot ce que j'ai des
supporteurs puis je leur donne des
produits goûtez-moi ça donnez moi un
feedback
je suis proche de mes clients si un
problème on règle tous je veux rien
savoir qu'un cas est un problème non pas
un produit qui poquet j'ai acheté un
produit qui se pose est arrivé chez eux
dans un bon état donc c'est un petit
problème on s'en occupe et j'ai déjà
fait cent sont des 10 km pour les portes
en bois
à une cliente tout simplement parce
qu'elle avait peur de pas l'avoir
atteinte une bonne cliente j'ai pris le
total est portée non aubry de faire ça
mais c'est pour moi ça fait partie de la
croissance de l'entreprise
mais ça c'est probablement la chose qui
s'est installée au podcast d'olivier
primo il faisait un peu de cadres et
puis luce lussi il m'a dit qu'ils
trouvaient que tu es plateforme de
facebook et qui était un haut niveau au
dessus même lui qui dit que beaucoup de
monde lundi je suis loin d'avoir comme
ce que françois lambert fait que sont
facebook c'est à dire d'avoir
constamment un contact direct avec ton
monde
mais si c'est ce qui fait la différence
et c'est ce qui me fait me lever à 3h du
matin non-stop ses jours par semaine je
le fais pas je me suis tu réponds à tout
le monde je réponds tout le monde -
nettement lama journée vous me demandez
ce que je fais là je suis j'ai monté les
femmes mais je réponds à tout le monde
sur toutes les plateformes il ya
personne d'autre qui m'aide c'est moi
qui le fait seul je suis débordé de
messages et des fois les gens me disent
et ont peu déçu par les jeux non pas
tant par les séparait pas à me
l'expliquer rapidement j'ai posé une
question en trois lignes puis je veux
exactement des voice mail que les gens
m'envoient sur les plateformes j'écoute
pour moi je lis en diagonale si ça fait
mon affaire on vaut plus loin mais faut
que je sois proche des gens c'est comme
ça et mon entreprise
les gens en font partie et j'ai des gens
qui ont rendu croissant 150 commandes il
ya déjà qui commande à toutes les
semaines chez nous non stop
on a des beaux produits mais ces gens là
font partie de la croissance puisqu'il
implique que j'ai zappé les 10 gardes
on s'en vont vers la corée du sud c'est
aux autres m'emmener love pas moi qui la
contactent et s'était donc j'utilise la
plateforme
j'utilise pas les gens je ne peux pas
dire ça mais on travaille ensemble oui
on travaille ensemble pierre à force de
travailler ensemble
on est en train de bâtir quelque chose
le fond qui créent de l'emploi dans une
région qui est pas favorisés qui fait
qui met des produits de l'avant qui
tient les râbles les producteurs
d'érable du québec gens qui ont dit le
québec est saturé dans le sirop d'érable
faut aller ailleurs
parfait ok c'est saturé dans la canne de
sirop d'érable 92 % des québécois une
canne de sirop d'érable dans le
frigidaire qui que du beurre pas tout le
monde les regarde juste au bye bye
il ya annoncé du sirop d'érable à minuit
soit ok mais je vaux prêcher pour ma
paroisse la meca sais que tu manges amis
du soir certainement peau du sirop
d'érable surprendra peut-être pourquoi
et rabat et du moringa les rabats de la
barbe à papa à l'érable mais si les
producteurs se mettre ensemble
si salah de rim et en deux ans on achète
à peu près entre 1 et 2% dépendamment de
ce que le québec produit deux pas de la
production du sirop d'érable et
transformant pas prendre en bourrique
par barbe à papa
après seulement deux années dont j en ai
je sens train de couvrir le québec un
peu un peu les états unis à travers
amazon donc parce que moi j'achète mon
sirop d'érable n'est pas assez loin
combines pour ça et cette année si on
produit 100 millions de livres
ça veut dire que moi j'en achète 2 %
d'acheteurs d'acheter 2 % des 100
millions de livres qui ont été produits
de sirop d'érable bois pour faire des
produits dérivés
exactement puis tab à 2 pour cent pour
cent qui transformait pas compte qu'en
meringue c'est que toi aussi tous ceux
qui font ce n'est que moi ce que
j'achète des barils de sirop d'érable
chéret plus quoi faire avec les barry
ville chez nous la suisse et six fours
remplissent presque un conteneur c'est
parce qu'on va pas y retourner mais des
bries à rendre volet retourne que ce
fait que le baril les mondes et achète
pour nourrir les ours
des fois les annonces facebook les gens
viennent en chercher
mais c'est ça donc je sa transformation
moi je sens train de couvrir le québec
n'est pas encore couverts le reste du
canada on veut à travers le canada on
vend un peu aux états unis mais j'étais
encore un micro puce fait que quand je
vois les producteurs d'érable du québec
qui disent que si le le le
l'érable et contingenté c'est faux parce
qu'on peut vendre beaucoup plus on
achète encore de l'autre coco aussi
alors qu'on a de l'eau d'érable baiano
d'érable finalement enfin on en vend
atone sur notre site de l'eau d'érable
pas la mienne mais on n'en vend et non
mais même jusqu'à pas tellement sur
l'eau d'érable que les gens pensent que
c'est à moi de produits par jean boiteux
les jo mais non parce que j'aime
beaucoup ce produit là donc à tellement
de choses à faire avec l'érable qui est
notre richesse au québec
et quand tu regardes que les gens
pensent qu'il faut aller à l'excès fois
l'international s'est même évident mais
on a encore un gros gros gros potentiel
et du siec juste dans la transformation
utiliser les rapts erronées les gens qui
connaissent le plus les rames
non pourquoi je vais à les éduquer les
gens dans un autre pays
tu devrais bouter les rares bourgades ça
goûte chaud ici j'ai pas besoin de vous
dire vous savez ça goûte l'érable
benjamin pop corn
jégo faisait à magog sa gouttes tombées
l'érable se sait déjà un système sûr
botswana racheter d'autres mais c'est ça
donc pourquoi essayer d'évangéliser
constamment les gens quand les gens ici
sont déjà vendus à l'idée qu'on leur
donne pas ce qu'ils veulent moi c'est ma
philosophie et ça marche c'est c'est
débile je n'aurais jamais j'aurais cru
que c'était aussi qu'est ce qu'un
roulement aussi un énorme les produits
dérivés danfoss que tulle c'est énorme
ça c'était non juste la pointe de
l'iceberg
oui c'est moi je veux vraiment que cette
entreprise là deviennent mondiale je
regarde une compagnie just call box
appelle des ânesses compagnie qui vient
d'arriver à la bourse et à la partie si
elle pourrait la voulait des couches
pour ses enfants simplement est ce une
compagnie maintenant qu'une valorisation
2.5 milliards
moi ça m'inspire ce genre de choses là
parce que est parti de couches
moi je partis de l'érable puis on va
voir où que ça va m'emmener les
valorisations je m'en fous je veux pas
gérer d'entreprise modifications gens
gèrent pas d'entreprise ma blonde que
j'aime gérer des employés gérer des
troupes ça m'intéresse pas pantoute la
sks que lui tu parles de cette business
là puis la proximité que tu as avec le
monde excuse même dans des entreprises
avant qu on travaille avec le centre
d'appels par exemple citer des proches
comme ça
j'ai toujours été là tu as toujours été
proche parce que bon les gens
travaillent chez moi mon rôle c'est ici
aussi au donc est en charge mais tout le
monde dans une entreprise que
l'entreprise fonctionne chacun son rôle
la personne qui veut répondre téléphone
est importante si elles mêmes leurs
revenus
mais bon on ne peut pas voir son revenu
si je promène écosystèmes à côté en
place donc c'est un échange ensemble et
pour moi c'est des humains qui étaient
là avec moi j'allais les voir j'avais un
comptable
il y avait jamais marcher le centre
d'appel 18 ou le tage il faudrait voir
les gens il travaillait comme comptable
il n'y a jamais été voir le centre
d'appels qui était à deux bureaux de lui
parce qu'avec l'illustration d'un bar il
ya les chèques de paye des employés me
l'ont jamais rencontré une jamais
rencontré puis abandonné lui dit ah
écoutons dépenses en tabarnouche d'un
crayon vaut couper crayon intérêts de
joie la rébellion dans le centre d'appel
lui disais ça parce qu'on dépense 4000
pièces par année mais un crayon mais
c'est sur une autre formule employée
pour tout le monde
moi même je vois un hôtel reprendre mais
moi je connaissais le jusqu'à près de
2000 employés je connaissais à peu près
les noms tout le monde ah ouais j'ai de
mémoire pas pire de ce côté-là fait que
je l'utilisé spi c'est et les gens fous
tu t'intéresses aux gens ce n'est pas
comme sur les péages comme à savon puis
j'écoute pas ta réponse
je demande comment ça vous fera prendre
le temps de l'écouter on fait fait que
les employés qui était clos depuis
longtemps que je voyais comment savent
aujourd'hui t'as pas l'air l'afflux de
fini par voir
moi je m'intéresse aux jean geiler pas
de sonner en vraie vie j'assume mais je
m'intéresse aux à celui qui te voyais le
titre a rencontré le 3 août leur cross
qui se souvient de ce qui s'y est dit
selon les gens web et justin trudeau
comme ça aussi mais j'ai rencontré deux
fois parce qu'il voulait que je me
présente et une fois j'étais au
parlement à woippy et et des coulisses
puis mais il ne boit bien bonjour que
françois comment savoir comment voter
garçon il s'en souvenait il raconte tout
le monde à travers canado
vielmas quelqu un qu avant mais temps de
rencontrer quelqu'un qui fait genre on
se rappelle le garçon je pense que c'est
pas pour rien qu'un gars comme justin
trudeau peut réussir parce qu'une
capacité de se souvenait dix rats les
gens important c'est qu'on aime ou pas
sa façon de gérer
il fait que quand tu lui parles tu fais
sentir important je pense que les gens
tout le monde aime se faire sentir
sentir que sont importants aux yeux de
quelqu'un et moi on regarde je me
présenterais plus jeune en politique ça
m'intéresse pas mais j'aime pas
tellement la façon que justin trudeau
gère mais la personne m'impressionne
mais il a du charisme comme la planète
entière à sa gaule me souviens pitt fait
sentir important et c'est ça c'est pour
ceux qui veulent rentrer encore pouvoir
rentrer pouvoir rentrer constamment nous
on en avait parlé aussi quand je regarde
la fois que tu la chose dans un
entreprise copain qui était satisfaite
on travaille c'est de sentir valorisé
une cimenterie
oui pis et les employés ce qu'ils
veulent plus jeune avait parlé la
dernière fois c'est un bon salaire des
responsabilités et de la liberté ici ce
que je m'efforce de mettre en place dans
l'entreprise modèle que je vois
quelqu'un je prends impliqués dans les
opérations mais quand je vois que les
gens que ce ça peut faire défaut c'est
ce genre de choses que je veux revenir
rectifier mais marilyn qui cherche t
elle des joies et des opérations est pas
mal bonne là dedans mais j'en viens au
contact avec le monde parce que ça me
fait capoter en fait deux types parce
que tu délègues beaucoup comme se dit
c'est toujours pas les opérations le
d'études et de ceux qui le délègue
énormément de tort mais tous des ligues
pot jamais répondre à la madame qui est
écrit que pose une question que c'est la
chose
j'ai quand même quelqu'un on est aux
yeux presque trois personnes qui
répondent aux gens à cliquer sur l'image
parce que je suis suivi par jour soit
maintenant j'ai pas seulement que lire
images sur facebook va les envoyer
quelqu'un qui gère l'eau qui sort de sa
cliente
oui ça c'est parce que de toute façon
j'ai aucune des on a bien trop de colis
maintenant
comprend on avance avant je le faisais
mais ils vont mais créé sur facebook un
jus telle affaire
c'est hier une fille qui met crédit gâte
ses thèmes à l'impact et les gibbons
walcott est assis qui parce qu'on est on
est des signes et c'est parce que
l'important pour nous est de port c'est
pas la commande 31 1504 ce fait été
emballé par le nom de la personne 15
heures subi mais mr opim est mort lundi
quand les gens préparent la commande il
a acquis ces péages quentin quand je le
connais lui c'est quand que des revues
qui fait débat c'est françois qui est
des célébrités qui nous qu'ils achètent
des produits et les gens regardent ils
ont vu leurs dons non c'est juste la
commande 31 500 4 me dont à liévin elles
achètent nos produits sont à la fois
qu'elle avait commandé la première fois
quand c'était le branle bas de combat
est-ce que des fois plus c'était pas
confortable de répondre à ça parce que
parce que tout le monde se sente client
a le même niveau mais des fois tu me
tiens un petit un petit beurre d'érable
de plus dans une commande de quelqu'un
qui n'aime pas signer des clients que je
fini par connaître six saisons que je
suis là ça fait 150 fois qu'elle
commence à bord ben oui pis ou quelqu'un
qui est particulièrement gentil où
quelque chose puis je suis le chef des
gardes ou des fois je vous écrivais
gardent leur au delà c'est un peu comme
quand on voit dans un bar v6 ou trop
même pas battre au même restaurant
c'est normal à manier qui vient de faire
un petit gratuite et ben c'est comme ça
aussi dans la vraie vie vous reconnaître
les gens mais on le fais je le fais
souvent au et puis même les gens
finissent au shopping finissent par
reconnaître qu'ils vont en profiter pour
l'occasion donnée donner quelque chose à
quelqu'un et ça fait partie fait partie
des temps à faire reconnaître tes bons
clients ben oui est ce qu'ils vont
commander fait ce testing peu de temps à
boire être même pas obstiné du gardon un
nouveau produit je te le donne
regarde cotations puis c'est normal de
faire des cadeaux
c'est la partie de la business à la la
faute était venu parler de sport un
petit avec une compétition
d'entrepreneurs locaux que tu nous avais
parlé piché que dans les dernières
années
testé beaucoup d'affaires pour ton mode
de vie que ce soit que tout que ce soit
les douches d'eau froide qui les
touchent nos frères qui sont devenus
virage puis c'est que ça fait c'est quoi
aujourd'hui mettant ta routine
quotidienne pis comment ce que ça peut
être de un an ta vie de deux dans
l'entrepreneuriat d'en être capable de
gérer les choses parce que maintenant
moi le chemin d'une page puisque je
m'entraîne vraiment beaucoup le
renseignement puis je déborde d'énergie
le plus que jamais puisque moi je savais
que c'était comme ma recette à moins de
mai quelle est la tienne est codifié
dans une journée le temps s'écoule et
trunks était adopté
l'entraînement fait partie de ma vie
mais l'entraînement via aussi
l'alimentation et
j'ai essayé quelque chose je dirais que
je suis plus low carb que kate au je
vais manger cadeaux à l'occasion mais je
veux pas être restrictif pied trouve
trop surveillé je me considère
flexitariens jeu pas végétarien si je
peux choisir quelque chose de
végétariens je vais le faire en même
temps
j'élève de cochon 300 paul-devot on est
quatre familles la thune mais ma routine
est très simple je dois m'entraîner tous
les jours
ouais ok mais j'ai inclus le jeune le
jeune internaute a que j'ai découvert il
ya peut-être deux ans et que j'ai essayé
j'ai fait face à manger dans le fond
c'est quoi ces de ces deux sites
c'est à une maintenant puisque je suis
habitué moi je fais maintenant j'arrête
de manger vers 7 heures le soir mais ton
je vais manger jusqu'à 4 à la main dont
je mange juste maintenant je fais oman
oil mélodique
oui et pour moi c'est l'aise j'ai
beaucoup d'énergie en faisant ce que je
vais faire des fois je vais peut-être
inclure un bouillon dos donc je fais
bouillir des os de poulet ou le dga ce
pied pendant 24 heures et j'ai toujours
au sol dans le frigidaire m'apprête à me
sauver leur peau
et je mange pas beaucoup de cadres
essaie de me contrôler j'ai 53 ans et je
regardais je tombais un article la
semaine passée les gens de mon argent un
taux de gras normalement de 30% et la
génétique voudrait que j'ai au moins 40%
toute grande famille et plus et j'ai
beau pour moi c'était un débat à chaque
matin je me lève me dit fullback la
génétique et le g 18% groupe ça m'énerve
et j'essaie de voir qu'est-ce que je
peux faire maintenant mais non seulement
ce sport juste le grand homme et un
grand goûter c'est pour vieillir en
santé c'est ce matin une nouveau
médicament qui est approuvé pour contre
l'alzheimer et pour prévenir l'alzheimer
ce qu'ils disent de fer entre autres
bien manger contrôle et en cholestérol
fait de l'exercice basse pression il le
jeune faisceaux en juin les jeunes
intermittents pige aux jeunes c'est
presque une fois par semaine
c'est assez rare que je sors d'une
semaine je referme 36 et 48 heures sans
manger régulièrement mais je continue à
m'entraîner je continuais fois par mois
je veux réussir la phase 3 des 12 ans
aussi si les conditions sont gagnantes
si je reçois de la visite ne mettra pas
faire ça aussi ma blonde et loches me
battre pas faire ça donc le jeune fait
partie de ma vie maintenant
oui car quand tu manges de soi un repos
mais ton tu peux aller t'entraîner le 1h
2h puis tous impôts tant d'énergie pour
t'entraîner people moi j'ai aucun
problème entre et dégagement traîne
maintenant je fais mon vidéo je me lève
à 3 heures et demie le matin je lis les
nouvelles je fais mon podcast ce matin
là les nouvelles à 6h30 s'est mis en
ligne 6h30 à 8h30 pendant que je réponds
aux premiers commentaires des gens je
m'entraîne maintenant j'ai installé jim
mais fatigante savez le vendre et
j'installe un jim dans mon garage
donc je retournerai plus dans un gym
m'entraîner 6h30 à 8h30 je suis najim
donc je m'entraîne la musculation
pendant deux heures par jour logements
répondant du monde en répondant du monde
c'est je pense le décès
je pense pas tu as aimé je m'entraîne
pour m'entraîner lui mais après ça je
regarde toujours la bourse - laleu
détruit dit j'en fais un beau coup là
j'en fais un peu moins parce que ça
prend du temps à se remettre dedans puis
mais je mange pas moi je peux je veux
manger le vers 1h pâte est ici je
vraiment chouette
je prends un café situé dans le fond
quant aux fins et cinq petits bois de
l'eau quinze minutes après s'être offert
un café puis la fin a fini par partir
deux jours après avoir mangé j'ai aucun
problème à fonctionner je m'entraîne
normalement mais c'est mon corps est
habitué et je me sens presque coupable
la 3e journée mais j'ai pas de problème
alimentaire il faut bien faire attention
que les gens qui ont des problèmes
alimentaires allez-vous pas la gueule
lancez-vous paula da pour maigrir et le
bronze pour les dépôts de maigret qu'il
faut ça fait parti d'un avantage
collatéral si on veut mais le but c'est
de s'entraîner et de fierté moi je veux
vieillir en santé et je regarde danse
commun ne serait-ce que les poches en
dessous des yeux quand j'ai pris ma
retraite quand j'ai vendu centres
d'appels
j'avais des poches en sus des yeux je
mangeais mal
j'avais beau faire des marathons en ce
temps là mais je mangeais pas bien je te
pauvres aussi pas nous y que je le suis
en ce moment maintenant je fais
attention à ce que je mange je me lève
le matin honnêtement j'ai des proches au
dessus des yeux mais la douche froide en
règle mais en nettement par hasard parce
que je m'en allais manger chez sophie
durocher et richard martineau meurent
éviter bien manger chez vous chez nous
pas fait je veux manger et de groupe
project sophie durocher avait écrit sur
le groupe project 2 go nettement
toujours et je suis très mal écouté
parce qu'elle savait pourquoi parler
avec les autres radios mais j'ai dit
hier à venait d'en parler mais je vous
écoute est tombé en syncope s'appelle
wemhoff et j'ai fait comme aion jalu
badauds fois d'embarquer danger des eaux
qui s'étoffe là mais je me sens bien et
ça fait partie de ma vie j'ai avant de
rentrer à big brother
j'ai fait un trou dans la glace jusqu'à
dernière le neuf et jallet 2 minutes
dans l'eau classé tout les jours et ça
fait partie de ma routine il est pour
une journée que je ne prends pas de
douche froide ça existe pas ma douche
est froide point final
sophie brochu on a reçu ces fibres
la pdg d'hydro-québec qui elle a dit ça
dans les dents les pics de demande
énergétique dans le fond c'est le monde
pouvait faire un effort collectif de
comme diminuer la consommation le
prendre des douches froides c est sûr ça
marche ici à montréal prendre notre
douche froide
c'est off parce que l'eau est froide à
montréal au chalet moment donné ma
blonde a dit mason qui a pas d'eau
chaude en poche il s'est pour sa part
dit deux mots du mois de mars au mois de
décembre on est au chalet j'ai jamais
prennent au chaud j'ai jamais allumée
l'eau chaude de ma vie moi de ma vie de
cette vidéo le départ à 9 mois enfin
camanettes me semble au show de baptiser
quand je vois la lui mais je ne sais pas
l'habitude de l'aduf la douche chaude
une habitude ou cités parce que dans ce
sens qui est quelqu'un que notre coach
je me souviens il y avait un petit goût
qui était dans le groupe qui venait de
porto rico pleut on finit l'ont fini
l'entraînement en triplant les coaches
sont pas prêts sort on peut on va se
rincer l'été dans la douche lutte et
liquides sont toutes les prennent leur
douche pis lui mais ça de schwann
piloter lors se déclenche rythme et à
deux fois mais tu as tout comme tout le
monde était comme ben quoi pour lui une
douche tes autres labos fait tellement
chaud que toutes les deux froide parce
que sade est rafraîchie mais lui son
attitude n'était pas de déranger pas en
tout 1 par le fait que prennent l'eau
froide
tandis que nous autres on recevait des
gouttelettes ces grosses stations d'être
sud
d'habitude et le djia gagne ça fait pas
mal et je me fais du bien tout
simplement mais à montréal à montréal je
vous le cache pas capable l'eau est trop
glacée d'embarquer le papier avoir manié
l'avait aussi le lac amance tiède et ge
a fini froide mais que je te jure que
quand et comment ces directs dessus des
excuses et cécile des couteaux le
quittera pas par des officines question
de mental finalement c'est quoi un peu
pourtant durci ajouté c'est autant la
dureté du monde
annette massé sûr que tu fait 4 ça fait
mal quand je parle de l'eau chaude à
froides à montréal je sens sans vivre
quand l'eau alary froide faut le vivre
mais une question d'attitude aussi pis
une question tu t'es ok ça m'amène quoi
lorsqu'on oublie sur le lot fois battu
dit ok ça m'amène des bénéfices non pour
deux minutes par jour ma voix toutes ses
bénéfices là en retour ben écoute de
minutes sur 24h capable d'endurer
mettons scientifiquement je pensais
quand-même controversé dans ce sens que
la science ont commencé à checker ou
enough
non mais c'est pas encore pas encore
finalisée mais tant les énorme bêtise
parce qu'il faut pas parce que oui bof
en plus d'ados froide qu'elle est
respiration et ils se proposent rien que
nous montre intelligente nous dit
respirer monis parce qu'on respire pas
et en faisant ses exercices de
respiration l'eau aussi est décédé 10
minutes par jour puis ça fait un bon
stage les peaux fais pas ce que je lis
le 10 minutes là mais c'est un peu de la
méditation moi c'est soyons un peu de
méditation weebe d'état mais dans une
autre jeune qui te fait sortir de ton
problème
pas de problème et fait sortir de ton
quotidiennement à 10 minutes pour
apprendre à respirer pu prendre le temps
et à negma quand je mets ma monde et il
jappe je stressais me direz spirel voilà
que mon rythme cardiaque épaules comme
d'habitude donc moi c'est des choses
comme ça que j'essaie d'incorporer dans
ma vie d'avoir du temps mais je teins
gossip tressés en partant donc pour moi
c'est il faut que je fasse que je
l'inclus dans mon horaire presque au
quart de tour parce que je veux oublier
puis je veux vivre sans témoin d'un
hommage au regard des gens qui
vieillissent mal
je regarde déjà le même mon fils yann
disait papa et si je regarde des gens
qui ont tournage ils ont pas l'être ton
âge mais je ne mentais lequel jeune et
je mets les chances de montbard pour
vieillir en santé moi ça me tente pas de
devenir un fardeau pour la société j'ai
quand même 53 ans donc techniquement
j'en aurais je regarde des gens qui
reçoit des 15,1 en a qui sont super en
forme qui en a d'autres vraiment qui
n'arrache je veux pas être ceux qui
n'arrache moi je vous êtes de ceux qui
sont en forme qui devienne pas un
fardeau pour la société ici si tu es
capable d'aller chercher un genre de t2
10 15 mm 20 ans de belvis qu'elle devine
qu'ils savent aussi j'ai pas d'argent
mais t'as tube énorme je regarde comme
dans ma famille haute pression
cholestérol diabète maladies cardiaques
moi j'ai rien d'autre j'ai absolument
aucun symptôme de sow mais chypre en
avant et qui dès que je vois que
j'invite de vie qui n'a pas de sens bien
je réajuste un moment donné est bon je
me pèse à chaque matin je vois au kg une
balance intelligente j'ai maman donc on
a 18 aujourd'hui qui nous permettent de
se donner des indices sont sans voiture
dans bonne direction à quel moment qu'on
rectifie cse je regarde mon auto moto de
grand pas pour le gros mais ce que le
gros abdominale est dangereux pour la
santé
donc si je fais attention parce que
c'est ma santé janvier qu'une donc moi
c'est ce que je veux une envie c'est de
battre la génétique le matin je me lève
heureux je me coucherai tout l'espoir
mais je me couche jamais enragé mais il
ya dix ans près d'un jour n'est qu'à des
moments que j'ai 53 ans me semble que
c'était quelque chose pas fait kim qui
rame d'essai des fois dans l'émission en
voulant de tifra toi 53 ans blandine
peut-être trop joué contre lui des
volumes d'activité commenté gagné tout
aimé
c'est pas parce que tu es je m'entraîne
et on s'est donné des gros des finances
j'aime kempé mois puis yann jamais battu
leur jeu les tenues toulon ou des fois
je les ai battus il ya un moment donné
dans la dernière semaine
j'entame ans ils sont premiers échos
beaucoup notamment il fait beaucoup de
bruit là c'est vraiment sport pas 10 km
cela pendant un mois j'ai tellement
couru dans ma vie qui n'entend pas -
c'est vrai des 6 me tient lundi on
s'emmerdait pont dit ok on fait chacun
20 km de course mais on le fait à coups
de 5 - 5 km au large par le tapis
roulant 5 km cambodgien km au large par
le tapis roulant et on le fait mais ça a
pris six heures après une demi-heure
après chaque et j'ai honnêtement 5 km
prendre une pause d'une heure je me
sentais raki comme si je venais faire un
marathon
c'était la seule c'était extrêmement
court et un peu plus élevé aussi
voudrais-je - le ça allait plus j'allais
plus vite parce que j'étais écoeuré le
dernier j'avais tellement mal aux
bandelettes parce qu'on est passés comme
chef couru peut-être même 50 km ça fait
vraiment mal et les derniers j'ai mis le
tapis roulant à 10 et demi plus
efficacement foule faut que je m'en
débarrasse 22 minutes à la fin le 5 km
on a eu de la misère à marcher mais j'ai
toujours relever les défis et qui
mettait toujours surprise ma faim elle
voyait plus mon âge au début elle voyait
assez sur l autre avantage et 53 dans le
technique masse d'une athlète de haut
niveau fait technique marge pour se
poser suivre cette fille là moi sur
papier mais je suis quand même un beau
père athlètes encore qui est capable de
suivre bêtement d'un bambin ou dépasser
tout simplement parce qu'il faut pas
d'âge
moi je pose de portes et a également
mené des choses que je pourrais pas de
faire comme avant la semaine et finale
mais le reste c'est de pauvres d'appui
de s'amuser puisse entraîner en
conséquence là je m'entraîne avec mon
bac
17 ans et il pose en tabarnouche se fait
à 6 pi 3 180 livres mais pour cette
grosse machine et
parce qu'il va les jouer au hockey aux
états unis donc faut que tu fasses
attention toutes ces macro mais si je
pense la même chose que lui le mien
était papier mais aussi n'hésitez pas
pris pour un allaitement moi je le vois
pas je le vois honnêtement je me lève le
matin des fois je m'étais bouaye que
leur fais mon âge ça dure cinq minutes
là si mal au dos le bon et le premier
cinq minutes que je me lève des fois
c'est pour ce projet je m'abonne habite
à côté de chez moi mon n'habitent pas
cent balles un enfant mais deux grands
18 depuis 20 ans faculté j'ai pas besoin
de m'occuper des autres la manger j'ai
une très belle vie métier je veux lever
à 3h du matin à 7h30 les mois pour jouer
le pôle web dormi mais dans ta routine
ont été ratés ont été rendues lutte
faisait le jim de six et demi a vite
émis puis après sa journée à je réponds
aux gens j'essaie toujours de penser aux
quais comment je peux amener des gens
sur mon site sans les amener sur mon
site ccc tu peux pas dire et garde je me
produis avant solo s'intéresse follement
foutu racontera l'histoire mais pour
bâtir son histoire prend du temps qu'est
ce que je vais écrire aujourd'hui moi je
toujours en train de penser qu'elle veut
qu est ce que je veux dire en vidéo dans
tôt puis je prépare mon vidéo du soir à
5 heures qu'est ce que je vous ai écrit
qu'est ce que je veux que les gens
retiennent de ce jour je vais toujours
parler d'entrepreneuriat c7 gagne là que
je veux parler mais qu'est ce que je
dois leur dire en même temps afin de
vidéos faut qu'ils finissent les 450 500
personnes qui sont en ligne faut qu'ils
finissent la vidéo qui viennent acheter
les produits
ça c'est mon objectif est-ce que c'est
réalisé à toutes les fois ça marche tout
le temps c'est pas que ça marche c'est
que j'ai un set en leur disant regardez
voici ce qu'on fait voici que servier
voici ce qui est là donc les vidéos a
toujours quand même un objectif de faire
grandir l'entreprise si ça marchait pas
je le ferai pas donc toute la journée il
faut que je me prépare à sont donc toute
ma journée - mind et j'écris quoi je
fais quoi comme vidéo je prépare quoi
pour ce soir je prépare quoi pour demain
matin
distin paquet c'est un peu quelque chose
entre-temps il ya des décisions à
prendre comme la mab l'on y attend toi
m'envoyer ok voici les noms des 25
chandelles qui s'en viennent au mois de
juillet fait que là je regarde donc et
c'est parfait dit non sont de la lune à
se trouver des noms en même temps mais
je suis obligée d'acheter un livre
aujourd'hui le jardin et lift avant de
m'en venir ici parce qu on est on
fournit plus à déplacer des palettes
donc un paquet de choses comme ça qu'une
entreprise en croissance les décisions à
prendre et j'essaie d'en planifier notre
entraînement l'après-midi ou le soir
non un petit entraînement training de 20
minutes en fin de journée pour faire un
peu de cardio donc puis après ça j'en
prépare le souper
mais c'est l'esprit pour moi je mange
beaucoup des choses qu'ils cuisent
rapidement fait que l'eau qui cuisent
longtemps on n'a pas sanctionné par ses
soutes étanches départ donc ma journée
saladerie mais juste planifiée qu'est ce
que je vais écrire répondre à tout le
monde qu'ils vont devenir des clients
potentiels
c'est l'autre jeune fille qui me répond
à françois je pense à une affaire dont
on aurait besoin 3500 points
je pense a dit capable fournée je sais
quoi très bas d'ici trois ans
salah de rien mais le prix de vente des
2 90 donc si une commande à 12 mai
pierre
enfin si j'y réponds pas allez peut-être
en train de regarder autre chose peut
pas fournir se trouve un moyen pour
former non mais pas une question
maintenant est la capacité de fonder son
on en fait plus que ça par jour donc ces
points 10 points problème mais moi
chacun des clients
pourquoi que je fais ça c'est que quand
je mens d'années j'ai voulu aller
m'acheter une auto mais je voulais
m'acheter une jetta en 1996 puis vendeur
il ya du verre qui lui a pas d'argent
pour s'acheter une jet on vous y propose
une golf il me proposait toujours la
golf moi c'est une joie que je vous
l'avoué ça m'avait fait chier tu me
respectes pas dans des hangars d'un
pauvre dont tu peux pas acheter une
jetta des troupeaux pour ça et pour moi
ya pas de petits clients je ne sais pas
qui je parle je sais pas s'ils quittent
son potentiel est donc pour moi j'ai
juste parlé aux clients ça fait partie
de ma journée remplie beyrède je regarde
la bourse quand je fais du des trainings
genre fin vidéo parce que les gens sont
intéressé par ça et j'ai pas de minutes
à moi d'en journée des fois je sais pas
ce que je fais mais je la prochaine
question à ce kit est ce que tu te
planifient des moments où tu fermes tout
petit peu à djabou ou ce sac suspect
dans la vie de françois robin sax espada
ma vie la blonde doit ce que vous faites
une bonne photo c'était aujourd'hui on
avait planifié une petite dette mais les
jeunes comme en quarante dernières
minutes pour n'avait plus fait qu'on a
décidé de rendre l'utile à l'agréable
c'est toi dans ta lamborghini avec quick
on lit partout autour parce qu'il ya pas
de cov le tew a pas de place pour les
jeux des cadets colis par tout ça qu'on
va manger une crème glacée pile entre
temps la propriété du métro à côté de la
crème glacée a dit françois j'ai pas su
des colis machicote mal été portée mais
ma blonde elle est là le besoin de toi
et moi franchement rend compte que les
gens ont besoin de la fin de semaine ce
travail aussi où on travaille tout le
temps ben mon frère est comme moi puis
l'affirmer schreiber que mon frère ma
soeur aux autres si j'ai un employé midi
françois j'ai jamais vu une famille ou
s'ils travaillent en duo devra faire
mais jamais personne charles ont fait le
vrai c'est ton frère à 2,14 au marathon
ouais ouais du travail qu il travaille
pour ce qu'ils nous aient cru que ça
fait que ça représente s'évitant tabac à
toutes les fois que je parle de ça c'est
les gens qui me disent benno ce passage
peut pas trop mon frère est une machine
de course là quoi c'est le troisième
meilleur temps de tordre québec
belmont dans le top 5 il y aura trois
coureurs dont tu allais bord de l'eau
que le premier puis la troisième temps
dans mon frère que le deuxième et
quatrième temps et de son ami michel
brochu que le cinquième temps à toutes
les meilleurs temps au marathon au
québec le 14
ça n'a pas de bon sens mais avec les
techniques d'entraînement d'aujourd'hui
qui se fera jamais bah oui parce que
c'était juste du gros volumes n'y avait
pas de musculation c'était coq rokocoko
qui avait fait sur le jeu ça m'intéresse
à chicago ça n'a pas de bon sens ouais
c'est à couiza un travail en web ainsi
sa faveur un certain talent pour avoir
le goût de travailler mais toi de san
luis et sur un boutre le plus
travaillant la planète terre si c'est
pas la mécanique qu'il faut te rends pas
de 14,91 ça y est
c'est une machine de course au maintien
mais mon frère moi y arriver chinois
cents à 7h30 7h30 le samedi matin et
dimanche matin jean-pierre qu'est ce
qu'on fait
lier prêtables à à partir de jeumont
fait même entraîner des fois il vient
chercher la piscine mais marlène elle a
besoin de pose de plus en plus à trouve
cinq ans la vie d'une start up
moi j'ai pas besoin d'eux comme un
poisson dans l'eau
je suis dans mon élément j'aime ce que
je fais je trouve seul fan en train de
bâtir quelque chose et je suppose que
c'est pas besoin de décrocher le goût
des grosses je suis pas capable je peux
pas capable de décrocher passer ma vie
m'a donné deux coups de patte du film
soit peu tout ça faire le beau et nager
alors que
lupin sorte de version de la wii mais
comme dernièrement je regarde sur
netflix ou au prime ou n'importe quoi
j'ai de la misère à trouver des bonnes
séries j'écoutais derniers mois une
série sur les designers du nom mais ce
sera fou mais c'était vraiment bon j'ai
besoin d'écouté moi des choses un peu
biographique pouvoir qui camac connais
pas je regarde ça je suis gamin qui a
bâti son empire et il sera encore son
linge son parfum qui est certain de ma
boîte quelque chose de plus grand que
lui 1 et 6 qui sait je me suis pas
capable de décrocher même là bas je
regarde un peu léger au regard d'une
cire en ce moment sur netflix sur les
pirates et c'est vraiment l'île de
nassau c'était lille des pirates est
vraiment vraiment bon et je me dis
comment que son parti de pirates à être
désirs les plus riches témoin c'est trop
comment qu'ils ont fait pour moi c'est
je m'ennuie d'une série comme la qos et
c'est parce que les criminels c'est des
entrepreneurs c'est juste que d'autres
cherchent à raccourcir entre le point a
au point b les autres veulent raccourcir
ce point au maximum minimum le désarroi
le plus proche possible alors que
l'entrepreneur veut le faire aussi ça
sera à prendre 5 c'est un genre qui
veulent avoir un mot de mots ne
serait-il pas le code de valeurs qui
vient avec le tiguan majorité des gens
ont critiqué non sens peut pas faire ça
mais comme grave
c'est sûr que ce genre de séries
loborika cache pas qu'une série le jeu
petit ce qui tue ce livre mais mais pour
moi décrocher je décroche et de quoi
c'est quand même j'ai pas besoin de plus
l'arrêter de m'entraîner mais je me
rends compte que fauche à travers ma
blonde a besoin d'un compromis pour
quelqu'un d'autre
ben oui était des fois même jeudi au
chalet en fin de semaine parce qu'elle
sait que je dois parler donc des fois
que j'accepte avance ammar est dérangé
que ma blonde me suive pas la fin de
semaine qu'on soit ensemble maintenant
honnêtement je laime le spawn question
de polémique mais je sais que je vais
taper ses nerfs fait que je sais que je
vais toujours vous passer un bon moment
avec moi si je sais que je suis débordé
je vois presse la convaincre mais vient
pas en fin de semaine toute façon je
serai pas là puis moi tu es nerveux
toute façon une fois que la banque au
premier
j'imagine que c'est le but le plus
excitant justement qu'un qu'il la
compagnie tu fais ce que tu as corse par
jeunes dans le fond le ticket tout est à
construire piqué tu vois vraiment les
étapes une à une
est ce qu'elle est ce que parce que dans
5 10 à tout va vous recherchez ce petit
beau tenter une nouvelle affaire dont
jean partira pas cette entreprise dans
le monde ont donc à ce moment là m'a
jamais vendu 2
quand ça à tête avec ça j'avais mondiale
pas quand maman rythme parce que je veux
pas cours et après subventions ça me
tente pas d'aller chercher du
financement externe des gens commencent
à me solliciter un grand nombre étaient
déçus pour besoin de m
je suis mon prof financier puis j'ai
grandi à même les fonds autogénérés donc
je pige pas juge pas la course pour
bâtir rapidement à tout prix le oui je
vais être rapidement parce que c'est sur
l'entrepreneuriat mais j'ai pas
l'obligation d'aller chercher des parts
de marché à tout prix puis avoir
quelqu'un pour rendre des comptes moi je
veux pas de financer nos mandants map
attente d'un minute que je vois
quelqu'un qui veut je vais décrochage
rapide phone
je pars en de conquête à une étape où
j'ai pas le goût de rendre de comptes à
personne autre qu aux clients comment
comment tu penses que tout ça va
repartir après la pandémie si l'on
commence de déconfinement en ce moment
et puis on peut imaginer que la vie va
reprendre son cours éventuellement
comment tu penses que le lait business
vont avoir changé pour la suite des
choses
ben je pense qu'elle télétravail
maintenant fait partie de la norme moi
même avant la pandémie embaucher
quelqu'un qui tape auprès de moi que
c'est existait pas notre dernier employé
ta3 revient on l'a jamais rencontré
jamais vu jamais rencontrés je sais même
pas ce que plaire je suis même un peu
d'eux ou marilyn allait certainement
elle le fait un zoom avec ea travail
avec mais je les ai pas vus mois ça
s'arrête pour fait partie de mes valeurs
avant autant mais non ça marche pau puis
ça marche ou pas c'est difficile donc
mais moi maintenant j'ai changé par
rapport à ça je m'en fous ce qui en
notant qu' compétences j'ai pas besoin
de savoir s'il fait bizarre ou pas des
enjeux rien savoir des hd capable faire
tout ce que je te demande et même plus
parce que je te demandais rien c'est moi
je demande à rien vous employez le tout
à fait là bas c'est faire tout heureux
c'est en fait plus
tant mieux mais donc si je pense que là
les grandes entreprises vont devoir
accepter honnêtement dernière fois que
j'allais au centre-ville alors de pointe
c'est déjà la radio et je regardais les
gens marchent et brûlé a alors pu piquer
le travail tout la tête hambourg
personne heureux il ya la plupart des
téléphones on est même obligé téléphone
le le bonheur respire peau est pris dans
le trafic pourtant mené par tourner dans
le trafic
on voudrait des cubicules tu parles pas
personne donc pourquoi tu vas travailler
un cubicule c'est cette notion là pour
moi elle est dépassée
on a besoin encore du face à face je
pense que une fois de temps en temps
faut aller se rencontrer sa règle ça a
aidé à régler beaucoup de problèmes mais
moi cette partie là l échange et l'autre
parti ait changé le commerçant lingua
nettement même folie puis cerise ça me
tente pas de grands magazines commande
en ligne
presque partout et ça ça va resté pareil
parce que ça permet d'avoir moins par
d'avoir moins peur de commander en ligne
sur commande et des légumes en ligne me
rouis vient délivrer mais sauf que bon
je peux marcher dans mon corps mois
autant que je peux le faire mais
donc c'est beaucoup de choses qui vont
changer le commerce en ligne et le pôle
est sûrement vraiment aider les
entrepreneurs parce que si ta seule
façon de vendre ton produit story tels
les marges sont sondés bill thies
l'image qui colle et les commerçants ce
prix noailles fond le fait que steve en
direct ont produit au consommateur c'est
sûr ça va aider beaucoup d'entreprises a
démarré puis est capable de rouler mais
c'est même le commerce en ligne beaucoup
de gens qui vont déchanter
parce que ok tu as peut-être pas un
pignon sur rue mais bon d'achat des
boîtes foutu pas tranché ping personnes
avaient péri le shopping alors d'amazon
ou très peu cher c'est comme les autres
banques allant battre saint piat super g
acheter quelque chose de 15 pièces une
charge sa espiasse jpeg
c'est ce que ça coûte c'est ce que ça
coûte pour envoyer un colis fait que je
t'achète en haut de 25 pièces ça va
coûter 6 95 au shopping pendant soixante
c'est gratuit mais tu vois le coup je
peux pas te permettre d'avoir quelque
chose que tu achètes pour qu'un espace
pour l'envoyer gratuit ça n'a pas de
sens les gens s'attendent à ça et il
reste que c'est dur a tiré sur moi moi
c'est un succès parce que j'ai la
vitrine québécoise les gens viendra pas
acheter du pas prendre à tout les jours
ça me prend autre chose donc en faisant
de la place aux entrepreneurs moi j'ai
développé une espèce d'amazon québec
mais je pense qu'elle a beaucoup qui
vont déchanter de 10 ans qui servait sa
clientèle
et pourtant c'est ce qui devrait faire
les gens ce qu'ils veulent regarde
toutes les entreprises qui ont survécu à
la pandémie
c'est le petit créée il ya une boutique
sur saint denis qui vend des stylos ok
pourquoi quand marche encore ces
cueilleurs tu rentres l'autre voix parle
à quelqu'un et jetant ainsi l'hôtel
façon mais tu vois il parlait il va
devoir en parler avec passion les
entrepreneurs passionnés ont réussi à
passer à travers la pandémie et je pense
que le retour du magasin général et
c'est vers l'eau qu'on s'envoie les
magasins avec quelqu'un qui t'accompagne
oui si tu veux pas arriver dans un
magasin pizza
que deux personnes se parlent de leurs
soirées à venir du samedi soir sont
honnêtement s'il faut voir un contact
humain puisse intéresser à la personne
en a parlé au début du podcast
je pense que ce haut ce que fait ce que
fait péter les entreprises dans le mode
pandémie c'est que le service à la
clientèle des polos la l'empathie du
client n'était pas là c'est comme moi
qui tu me dérange toi c'est fini ça pour
moi le retour du magasin général
la proximité d'aller jose avec quelqu'un
les gens ont besoin de josé même se font
en ligne
et pourquoi j'ai du succès en ligne ce
que charles zech les gens les gens
veulent pas venir acheter chez vous il
va venir acheter parce que signé par les
piments j'ai goûté à ton propre vie mais
le disent après vivier moi je le dis je
me souviens d'un feedback vraiment bon
ton pas prendre au garçonnet là il y
avait quelque chose de mauvais match ça
arrive tout le temps mais je pense que
l'après pandémie va ressembler
probablement des années 50
le magasin général allez j'ose avec la
personne prendre le temps d'aller voir
depuis qu'il a personne ne connaisse les
gens aiment se faire reconnaître
moi ce que j'ai changé pour toujours où
j'ai pu besoin de me présenter à magadan
dans un bureau mais employons pas besoin
de se présenter au bureau parce qu'ils
travaillent dans l'entreprise
mais effectivement que ce contact mail
c'est le seul avantage quel magasin qui
a pignon sur rue au sol que massa en
ligne très peace is it en prophète
popsci smith pas là-dessus il n'y a
aucune raison pour que tu te bats tu
peux le faire
tu peux c'est maxime tu es là tu peux
aller chercher ces réseaux sociaux aussi
ce que j'ai réussi à faire c'est parce
que je regarde des pages entrepreneuriat
des pages entreprises puis je me dis oh
my god que vous n'êtes pas de date
vous avez 500 mais donnez moi cinq cent
mille personnes qui me suivent ma page
en et 115 me donnes moi cinq cent mille
personnes je vais te bâtir un empire
parce que je vais m'occuper des gens je
veux donner moi je regarde mes vidéos
qui marche là ok pourquoi qui marchait
pourquoi capot marché et j'analyse à
chaque jour à qui cette fois là j'étais
pas correct ça n'a pas marché les gens
prennent le temps analysé des statuts
qui fonctionne pour aller chercher de la
clientèle
je veux un homme est un jeu l'aiment
beaucoup mais je trouve qu'ils
essaieraient sa présence les réseaux
sociaux est pas bonne c'est ricardo
ricardo à 500 sur les quinze mille
personnes le monde capote sur ricardo
tourner cherche une recette qui tombe
sur le cadeau systématiquement legault
et juste avec juste avec les clics sur
sa page que les publicités sur sa page
d'ofer descente milliers de joueurs
imagine toi qui s'y intégrer sa page
facebook avec la chope facebook pika qui
parlent même d'une recette qui fait plus
la spatule kitag la manger tagmé
produits dans toute la france dans
toutes les affaires moi j'ai voit que
les produits sont aguerris les gens
s'ils faisaient ça il est tellement des
millions et des millions sans table les
gens veulent acheter
c'est impressionnant quand ma légende ce
juste le regarde on vient faire là on a
fait un savon barbe à papa c'est notre
mégot met dix ans la barbe à papa
l'érable non à la hisse à la barbe à
papa commercial les enfants et les
enfants cas pas que le savon est beau il
fait chaud il fait à partir de lait de
brebis avec une fragrance bavard mais ça
sent bon les gens veulent capote ici on
est plus en stock
donc parce que je le tague que les gens
l'achètent donc quand je regarde d'une
entreprise comme lui ils sont tous comme
ça donnait 1 va rapprocher eric addo un
mégot succès et a fait vider la levure
au québec au début de la pandémie parce
qu'elle fait un vidéo qui a fait le pain
maison ses loques puis sa page facebook
son taux d'engagement au explosé mais
pour maintenir et c'est ça qu'il faut
maintenir c'est la présence puis de
donner aux gens ce qu'ils ont un goût de
voir et d'entendre
moi j'aime beaucoup le kolkhoze brou
koffi lequel fait plusieurs fois
ils seraient plusieurs fois jaugeas vous
montrez vous allez voir c'est facile à
faire je le fais pas pleinement
catastrophe la catastrophe en
catastrophe
l'autre jour j'essaie de le faire avec
moi mais pas encore assez bon pour fin
mai figure pour le monde tremble pas et
je regarde aussi des entreprises
tellement grosse que ses claques et
ricardo lui-même un genre pas du tout sa
page facebook probablement le nom mais
il pourra voir une équipe
deux réseaux sociaux devant tic et
cartes cadeaux lubrique et ricardo l'un
il ya déjà des caméras sommes aussi j'en
ai camero chez nous et le savoir
quelqu'un a dit oh regarde toi tu fais
sol et nous on va le mettre en ligne
fêtes d'arras et on s'occupe du reste
on s'occupe du reste là ça se voit
maintenant faire la foire lalla le shop
sur facebook et les tags et les trucs tu
utilises ya pas besoin d'être juste
hague et les produits d'avoir le
facebook shop est un homme lui parce
qu'il y avait sorti a fait une sortie
l'année passée initiative a besoin de 10
millions pour bâtir son site web puis
7,2 millions le réinvente pas la roue 2
millions public avait besoin de cela
oui oui tu vas leur donner une partie
ton profit mais tarp au 25 programmes
arrêtés problème à temps plein mais oui
ça d'où votre après avoir écouté ces
normes et moi quand je pose les vsig pas
les dg pas prétention mais ce que je
fais fonctionne et ce que je fais je
regarde comme dit en compagnie de
jessica alba
je regarde leur page facebook 2.1
millions 14 like sur le nez dessus ok
allez succès ailleurs méthode 2.1
millions de personnes qui sont prêts à
venez voir ce que tu as à vendre a
proposé tu mets des photos qui sont peau
accrochante les gens pensent que une
belle photo ça accroche mes meilleures
photos le moi sur mes statuts l' une des
photos qui comme le plus et moc mon
frère on a rempli la vente de propofol
travaillé l'année passée toute la fin de
semaine à faire puis je rappeler ok 2 go
avec un filet à sa page les vrais label
sub pop corn sur ma page facebook c'est
de la faute au cumul plus d être une
photo mal prise avec un iphone mais qui
remplit de dentiste et ses huit frères
une belle photo là c'est sûr que si tu
peux avoir d'authenticité
une belle photo c'est encore meilleur
mais leur en avait pas et c'était le
moment sur le moment était fier ont
travaillé ça partait dans les mac si on
était fiers de notre coup je les prix
bingo ça a marché aux bretons baubeau
dow est le mot-clé authenticité c'est
vraiment ce ppi
c'est ce qui explique le succès
justement des influenceurs le versus
team et ondes que qu'une personne qui
peut vraiment rien à vendre plus que ce
rapport les pubs qui à cappone se
montrent des following incroyable de
200000 personnes versus des compagnies
qui essaient qui met du contenu de la
foi mais quand c'est pas personnel
quatre postes que espèce de contacter le
médecin influençable
bon il y en a qui font juste montrer
leur corps je me dis qu'ils ont dit oui
incroyable mais je me dis ok ce parce
que ton corps m'a donné pourquoi le
vendre tout avis faut que tu aies autre
chose puis j'en regarde d'autres sans la
nommer je trouve qui a fait une belle
job c'est catherine beach je trouve qu a
fait une belle job sera la plus gay je
sais pas ce qui advint mais je pense
qu'alain show de télé à ce moment c'est
ce genre de personne que je vais suivre
médicaux mais qui en fait pour bâtir
trois cent cinquante mille personnes
je regarde comme lisanne nadeau lysanne
écoute à l'ewi exceptionnel et puisque
le monde l'ont suivi dans ma longtemps
comme l'a fait ces gens là ils ont été
capables de bâtir un auditoire et d'en
vivre
parce que c'est ça le foot et c'est le
fait d'avoir ben déjà mais ce n'est pas
capable de mener monétiser ça donne quoi
avoir le moral
mais je regarde ces gens là ils semblent
les andalous monétise lan envie de ça
carine piccio si assemble le faible je
regarde même geste que dénommé et ont
fait pas pour être fautive de tarnos
mais qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour
vive après lançons une compagnie donc je
regarde ces gens là bas toi tu en est un
exemple s'ils n'ont cessé
je regarde ça je me dis ok gens qui ont
réussi à monétiser leurs contenus et
sincères lorsqu'on parle de cours je te
suis le genevois le petit vendangé dans
le goût de comprendre ok ok c'est vrai
n'a retrouvé moi j'ai pas d'argent mais
j'ai vu ta photo j'ai fait comme depuis
ma première mais maintenant on peut si
on veut parler d'influencés maintenant
on le sait
moi je me suis fait depuis catherine
c'est le même principe dans cette gare
aux chutes à odéon n'est sorti de là
avec boom un gros fardeau à canteleu pas
construit tu sais pas quoi faire et que
sa tête et c'est de faire des affaires
le titille fait des trucs tard sans
poppy puis moi c'est comme dans le
dernier dans dernières années que j'ai
commencé à faire qu'est - dans le fond
ce que je faisais avant puis moi c'est
du sport fake je manque au risque le
monde disait tu veux juste parler de ce
pauvre mais c'est ce que je fais mais
c'est juste que je fais fait que le
cégep et il sait ce qu'est devenu le
plus authentique depuis que j'ai
commencé à faire ce que j'ai le plus
d'interaction avec les gens les gens
m'écrivent veulent des conseils des
trucs tpiy course à pied je peux pas
vraiment donné de conseils parce que je
suis un coureur correct pour un
incroyable coureurs mais mettons
natation le jeu peut en donner des
conseils j'ai coaché pendant longtemps
c'est comme je connaissais l'éthique
fait que le monde m'écrivent puis c'est
vraiment cool c'est puis justement le
travail sur un produit sur des
suppléments pour le sport d'endurance
fait que pendant wasquehal gens dans des
cases avec avec électrolytes puis piqué
seul monde sont super intéressé bien
attendre j'attends que ça arrive parce
que c'est de ça que je parle c'est avec
le monde qui me suivent même su pour ce
fait que c'est comme si ça vient
organique ccc mieux je trouve ses hôtes
même moi je vis pas mal mieux examen
faut jamais oublier pourquoi les gens
nous suivent moitié comme labour semis
story qui prennent le plus soin dès que
je parle un peu de bourses
ça devient fou logeable comprend ok mais
de mathaf et puis comment tu fais
comment
ma passion depuis j'ai étudié la dame
noire à 1987 j'ai utilisé est là dedans
je voulais travailler dans j'ai craint
le chien en 1990 là dessus j'ai fait
toute ma carrière là-dessus j'ai perdu
tellement d'argent que j'ai appris
comment faire et ça ça pogne quand je
parle de cash cadeaux fois dans le monde
capote lasser les interactions les pulls
et les gens comprennent pas fou c'est la
même chose quand je donne des
conférences végétaux l'impression que je
me répète mais les gens qui viennent
sont en salle aux autres m'ont jamais
exactement faut jamais indirectement
liés que c'est qu'on regarde instruit
dix secondes cinq secondes quand même
qu'à t'en parle
le lendemain j'ai dit je me dis pas il
parle encore d'autres sur ben non je te
suis pour ça c'est ce que je suis pour
ça c'est ce exact puisque ça c'est un
danger que moi je me suis fait prendre
un peu amener jugeant un ou deux
commentaires de personnes de mon
entourage je faisais white historique de
sport mais c'est parce que ces gens
c'est ma soeur père regarde
systématiquement toutes les affaires que
je fais à toutes les fouette amener l ça
se peut que je suis seul qu'elle ait
qu'un su il est effectué ça se peut que
je l'attend mais au final toutes les
autres personnes qui gèrent les affaires
ils n'ont pas vu cette semaine le sillon
peu suivi sauf pour ceux qui veulent
habiter ou si c'est au début mais tombe
donc pour ça mais rien petit n'a parlé
faute de sport allemand enfin le voyons
ph aura des sports mais qu'at-il fait
pendant assez longtemps
c'est quand même chipé à cheval de sport
chaque fois que tu charges des quads en
émettant jusqu'à qu'on était dans ta
cuisine mettons c'est objectivement le
set up qu'on est ici 100 fois mieux
sauf que juge juste maintenant il ya un
changement dans avant on faisait ça dans
un set up l'on change pour cela il y
avait des commentaires des gens m'ont
jamais mieux la cuisine il faut
calmement mieux
une fois que les habitués au changement
[Musique]
les gens suivent ces gens ben c'est ce
qu'il faut rester mois ce qui marche et
le dentiste et vg à chaque fois que je
mène story est authentique et vraie et
senti des vidéos aussi mais mes vidéos
exactement étoile du mois puis a
nettement plus de monde dix le matin
change tout le temps
ok on va vous expliquer pourquoi je
chante il ya bien plus de riaillé rien
que je fais qui toise à acquérir deux
heures j'aime chanter sacha que je
chante comme un pied mais je le sais que
chantôme et puis en partant non mais
c'est parce qu'à un moment donné c'est
qu'avec facebook
bon j'ai parlé monétisation sur facebook
que j'ai perdu mais facebook
m avoir un moment après la minute parce
que du contraire mais youtube et autour
votre maître vidéo une peuvent en
partant apprécié votre en place et
quelques-unes donc / 20 minutes la céda
pas avoir plus que 3 peu 4e maxime
attention et vidéos de 22 minutes sinon
ça tape sénat rouge en mai avoir quelque
peu à l'occasion des gens savent que ces
donna donne à ccc normale et elle m'a
donné en apprenant sur la voie du succès
1 pour monétiser des affaires sur les
réseaux sociaux il faut que tu
comprennes l'algorithme et je cherche un
moyen pour faire une pause après deux
minutes parce que facebook places pas sa
pub au début parce que quand se
déroulent sont venus facebook mais il
faut commencer à jouer le vis des autres
et ce après minute qui va te placer une
vidéo fait j'ai commencé à faire au
québec soit parle un peu la pression je
prenne une pause je veux donner une
écran droite et moi j'ai habituel donc
je peux me permettre
et mes revenus ont explosé quand j'ai
commencé à chanter dans le monde restera
pourtant tant que chanteuse non parce
que il y avait là il y avait la pub de
placer ce qui est important parce
qu'après ce que tu sais pas si les gens
vont te fais 15 20 minutes 25 minutes
les deux vidéos mais il sait qu'après
deux minutes s'étaient parlé d attirer
égard je vais vous parler d'autres
fidèles à faire c'est ce que je fais
maintenant je présente mes mains mes
sujets et à exactement 2 minutes en ce
moment c'est la même chose je fais un
écran noir
je fais de change dont il dispose et je
fais une chanson qui te calmes 15
secondes on m ait raté la plupart du
temps fait
il est mon dangereuse donc juste le fait
que jean les gens jasent d'un
commentaire ça amène d'engagement ce qui
est important dans les réseaux sociaux
et itouch en des biens matin entre la
peau et celle de sa de la tonne me
restait dans tête d'or survive on passe
à côté du sujet puis vont parler de la
chanson de la chanson me permet de
positionner une pub en même temps ça que
se soit coupé dont au point de vue
engagement au point de vue pub pour que
les réseaux ça soit elle ce soit payant
b et stratégies tout le monde chante pas
juste pour la forme je les fais parce
que je me suis amusé et j'y vais comme
ailleurs ok c'est vraiment pas hier mais
bing gros on les compare maintenant dans
le sol c'est fou parce que tu es teinte
et un téton entrepreneur d'une autre
génération c'est dans le sens où tu ne
t'étais pas t'étonner dans instagram
al'inverse nous on n'est pas né dans un
style non plus mais on met ton presque
squelettique dans facebook facebook on
était jeunes saisonniers sauf que tout
au contraire de plusieurs tout pas
tourner le dos à aux réseaux sociaux ou
au contraire on dirait que tu es con
brad et comprend plus que moins vendu
très cher analyse à tout les jours un
héritier comme là j'ai perdu ma
monétisation de facebook parce qu'ils
pensent que je teins politiciens ça
m'énerve parce que c'est pas drôle parce
que si tu joues la gamme de facebook
facebook shoot again
donc ça veut dire que si tu monitise des
vidéos ils vont aller présenter à plus
de gens parce qu'ils veulent faire de
l'argent
maman une utilisation donc mon
engagement est moins fort
quand j'ai travaillé encore plus fort
parce qu'ils présentent systématiquement
à moins de personnel mais je touchais de
encore être plus imaginatif pour pour le
faire
donc ça me fâche un peu parce que c'est
des clients de moins donc obligés de
faire plus de cette super jo des
différentes des différentes entreprises
cherchent à peu près tout le monde
possible d'ouvrir travailler deux fois
plus fort peau parce qu'ils me pense
quand même il donc
j'analyse j'essaie de leur part les
bleus je me dis ok parfait et en même
temps quand je dis tout le temps qui est
une opportunité je me dis moi même j'ai
pas assez développée youtube
pourquoi que j'ai cent quinze mille
personnes qui me suivent sur facebook je
les 35000 sur instagram tardivement
occuper autant que les autres places
neigé seulement 6500 sur youtube ça pas
de sens donc c'est un leurre sur youtube
je mets toutes les vidéos sud feu
j'émettais mais comme une librairie
il ya maintenant je travaille pas mal
plus avec youtube le pas le choix c'est
vrai mais je l'avais délaissé si j'avais
travaillé les réseaux tout en même temps
j'aurais peut-être cent mille personnes
sur youtube et ici les gens sont autant
sur youtube que sur facebook sur tik tok
maintenant comme langage à celle
d'amener un angle 70 puis j'ai regardé
qui ce qu'ils peignent entrepreneurs ces
jeunes ours est le mois le cheval de
bois cependant durban are you je parle
de gens je parle de santé donc comment
je peux me positionner pour avoir un
succès tictoc seront pas des danses tab
arnaud choquet de la femme
mais ces photos
mon but est toujours de monétiser et de
demandes est ici chacun des affaires est
ce que mon temps passé sur facebook sur
youtube est payant la réponse est oui
est ce que ces gens là peuvent devenir
des clients la réponse est oui et c'est
pour ça que je continue mais j'ai
comprends pas ce que j'ai analyse chacun
de mes statuts je regarde qui pourquoi
ya pas nier lui pourquoi lui est propre
à nier à calar que je les publier ce
type de statut a promis à 10h pense à
deux ans de prêt midi à midi à 5h à 7h
le soir donc puis savary le dépendamment
du statut le chemin de belles photos sur
instagram avoir être plus apte à le
croire si je fais un statut
entrepreneuriale ben je vais la voir
toute la journée qui roule pour que les
gens au bureau plus en parler donc ça ne
parlera pas le soir parce qu'il y aura
pas des changes comme un matin j'en ai
criant bella je la vois qui je lai qui
est de l'engagement par rapport à ça
parce que je te souhaite un texte que
j'ai lu le journal de montréal donc
j'analyse constamment eu aucun des
statuts qui est laissée à
l'huile à lui il faut je regarde
pourquoi le poignet pourquoi le propos
nier et qu'est ce qui s'est passé est ce
que ma maman ma première ligne de texte
est bon à ce que ma faim et à bonne
saucisse est important dans mes vidéos
pourquoi ils peignent ou pompes pour
chacun des choses comme jane eyre jeudi
passé il ya explosé j'ai beau regarder
je comprends pas je comprends pas que
j'ai fait de différent le jeudi ou le
vendredi alors qu'ils étaient publiés à
même heure le matin je ne comprends pas
pourquoi il ya plus pogné je regarde les
nouvelles n'étaient pas moins
intéressante le vendredi mais jeudi
passé ça a explosé
j'ai peut-être à l'esprit du jeu pas
capable d'aller rechercher sur reach là
aussi fort que je lui dis passé je ne
comprends pas pourquoi et ça ça m'énerve
quand je comprends pas pourquoi parce
que je comprends c'est l'ex droite
finale
mais c'est quand même même avec 6500
personnes qui me suivent sur youtube il
ya bien des youtube ac serait jaloux de
mes revenus quand même inscrit
l'engagement c'est ça que youtube
cherche c'est de l'engagement et c'est
je regarde les en ado avait déjà parlé
avec avec lotto a fait 66 medias je
faisais parler de mes revenus le de
facebook ce projet divise et on parle de
150 et 175 pièces de revenus que je les
ai perdus est énorme et parce que chaque
petite chose et monétiser sans taper ses
nerfs dès juin que je prenne ce que j'ai
fait sur facebook et que la main sur
youtube mais c'est de ma faute
on est deux macaques marivin une
problématique comme ça je me dis
pourquoi j'ai délaissé les autres alors
que j'aurais pu y travailler les trous
mais ça prend du temps mais ça prend du
temps à bâtir une entreprise aussi meba
force maintenant si d'interagir avec les
gens pour les amener éventuellement être
des clients futur parce que clairement
la philosophie de voir chaque chose qui
arrive comme positivement puisse mettre
en mode solution de l'apli xi parce que
me perdre est revenu sur 5000 par année
à cause de facebook par alves jour au
lendemain
je ne suis pas un politicien comme dix
gardes sata pour respecter la règle de
facebook
je vais corriger si tu fais des vidéos
que facebook veut pas voir mais comme
des moines est il un vidéo savons
comment enlève tout au complet alors que
ça fait partie de mon modèle d'affaires
l'aja trouve pas drôle parce que je ne
suis pas un politicien et la raison
pourquoi qui m'ont tout enlever ils
disent tu est un politicien mais je ne
suis pas un politicien c'est ce qui
c'est ce qui me fâche c'est que je suis
pas la personne c'est l'intelligence
artificielle qui me mélange à quelqu'un
d'autre
native puis je peux plus débarqué de ce
scénario là ça ça m'énerve aux boîtes
parce que c'est ce n'est que justice que
je parle avec les gens sur facebook chez
facebook me disait un peu pareil là
dessus tu parles pas l'actualité par
l'entrepreneuriat
là tu parles sujet et j'aborde jamais le
sujet de la coved pour moi je vais au
débutant par la pelouse par le nombre de
copies
la décision des gouverneurs à baho
décision du gouvernement mais j'aimais
pour dire le gouvernement le complotisme
où ça m'intéresse pas le gouvernement je
persiste à croire que il veut notre
biais cours ok il veut pas nous mais il
veut pas nous insérer une puce une part
il veut pas nous contrôler a à ce point
il a lutté si tu oublie de prendre des
décisions pour s'assurer que pierre voit
que l'édition compris bagarre dont on
attendrait de sortir finalement parce qu
un vaccin parce que les gens se sont
fait vacciner on s'en va dans la bonne
direction contre eux pour ou contre il
reste cavale vaccin il y avait beaucoup
de gens qui étaient malades
maintenant c'est de là que c'est pas des
sujets que j'aborde est-ce que je tape
ses doigts des politiciens ben oui je
tape des fusées fatigue est bonne pour
moi est une tête de tueur que parfaite
denis coderre je m'amuse avec lui
valérie de plantu ma bus et des
politiciens s'amusent à que je m'amuse
littéralement à les imiter
puis avoir du fun n'y a rien de méchant
des imitations ne fait toujours pas ce
que il parle tout le temps
il veut tout voir la note
depuis dernièrement dénigrement s'est
mis comme des bracelets comme un jeune
habitant imed et habib stop un peu il
est à quoi ces bracelets de jeunes qui
va avoir de la cool alors puis parle
tout le temps
fallait il se met toujours la face comme
ça qui fait sauter les limites avec une
nouvelle de lui
je chante autant des mots dogmatique
pitot d afrique finissants et qui aime
son médecin dans une conversation fait
que ça fait partie
rambo gauthier je m'amuse inclut une
matin aussi quand que je parle de
syndicalistes jugé moody's à
entrepreneur exploiteurs qui prend du
scotch à 3 heures l'après midi donc s'il
ya des personnages dans mes shows qui
sont récurrents puis bon les politiciens
font partie mais c'est à rien de
controversé pas à ces drôles plus
qu'autre chose et pour bannir ton compte
notamment de s'assurer non répond alex
que c'est moi je crois à la santé
publique je crois aux mesures sanitaires
des poteaux pas d'appel à la haine non
plus noté d'enfants n'ont jamais jamais
jamais jamais je vous demande et on
ressent bataille de facebook il ya peu
j'essaye de comprendre mais ils disent
frein la page françois lambert et managé
par
des politiciens où il était un
politicien pour ça mais on veut pas que
les politiciens puissent monétiser leurs
affaires il est obligé de dalles écueil
un apport de facebook pour te faire
écouter qui perdait on va parler des
comptes d'instagram du monde qui perdait
que la solution ça a été de voler
jusqu'en californie d'aller au bureau
d'al et largement vopos tant que je
parle pas quelqu'un qui peut m'aider
mais je trouve ça bizarre quand même
qu'une entreprise aussi grande que ce
titre pas avec amazon d'un problème et
on connais tu peux pas là quelqu'un tout
de suite il dit le rembourse août en
renvoie un autre en charge rien sans
demander de preuves
exactement puis facebook est plus
rentable d'amazon presse était pas
capable de parler avec quelqu'un pour
dire quatre voici ma problématique je
suis vérifier je suis françois lambert
au québec voici mon site web
gogol moi tu vas voir toutes mes
anciennes blonde disons tous non encore
mais de moins en moins finalement parce
qu'avant google est il est en cours
banco pied d'un couple parental françois
lambert était de produits frais au moins
c'est plus mais bon je les donne le site
web
je le donne gago gaulle moi la garde
vous êtes aux états unis donc vous
connaissez le big brother ou gaby
bonnand policiers j'essaye toutes sortes
de trucs pour lowe's et garder chez
vérifiez vous avez mon passeport vous
voyez bien france en affaires c'est
vraiment un pack par les dettes il ya
faute et un son chaud le matin puis soir
puis je le tiens parler de broder aussi
pour quand est venue d'italie
vous avez compté jeu presque parfait
pour ce que c'est dans les places que tu
risques de te voir atv encore
prochainement ce qu'est ce que c'est
quelque chose que tu veux encore faim
mais à certains de leurs yeux plusieurs
offres donc on me proposait deux trois
shows métier sa part a du talent on
parle d'un show large triplettes au mois
de mars l'année prochaine qui voit une
vraie donc on m'avait repos intellij y
en avait 2 3 alors qu'ils n'étaient que
16 18 que c'est enregistré et il ya
tellement donc je pense pas être
télévision dans les deux trois
prochaines années
c'est pas quelque chose que je cours
après c'est si ça se présente mais
honnêtement je me lève le matin j'ai mon
studio notre sol
jean régis je rejoins en moyenne
cinquante mille personnes à chaque matin
cinquante mille voix enfin que pas
tellement qu'ils écoutent la vidéo mais
eux au moins le texte l'on veut y ont vu
leur mort reach est en moyenne de
cinquante mille en moyenne dans les
dents des vidéos normal quand je fais
des vidéos de bourse on parle de 300
milles de reach je bouge pas mes fesses
de chez moi donc est-ce que je suis
pressé d'aller faire un show dans une
chaîne spécialisée ou qui vont être
coûté par 5000 personnes
jusqu'à ce soir sur un projet
d'entreprise mon prochain projet att lit
je veux réellement faire big brother
canada
je veux vraiment moi j'adore réseau puis
je vais aller le vivre comme incognito
et non pas comme personne connue est ce
que je serais capable de passer au
travers
j'aimerais bien cela suppose tout petit
incognito sur un petit google puis les
gens parce qu'il arrive il y avait dix
agriculteurs
ça c'est jackie chan double
les autres non plus c'est un poster qui
part oui je m'appelle france oui j'ai
deux garçons ce qui est vrai oui j'ai
étudié en finance à ma demande j'ai pas
aimé saut c'est vrai tout est vrai c'est
vrai que je ne ferme
est-ce que j'ai des moutons c'est vrai
que j'ai des moutons encore actuellement
est-ce qu'on a eu beaucoup on a eu 700
donc j'ai été élevé donc je peux parler
moutons avis et c'est ce que je parlais
jeu tactique ultra léger les vrais
moutons dans pour moi je deviens
sympathique de cause des postes la
personne à abattre pour point de vue
physique qui vont voir que je capable de
battre avec les autres quand même dix
ans 25 ans j'aimerais ça est-ce que
c'est possible il faut utiliser mes
contacts pour essayer de me faire
inviter mes sabots du cheval l'aide mais
j'aimerais ça et sow ce serait beau
projet l'année prochaine je te souhaite
de payer la banque jean thomas parce que
votre baignoire et j'en ai été bon ok
mais il était très bon camp - il y avait
tout le monde dans sa poche
oui l'année oui mais
pete est capable aussi de faire faire
aux autres c'est plein je veux mettre
là-dedans parce que les deux travaillent
ensemble les deux sincèrement on s'est
rendus loin parce qu'on avait la même
approche lui c'est sûr que moi je plusse
bulldozers lui est plus empathique et
hintermann il faut jouer avec notre
personnalité
on avait un sens s'est rendu tout les
deux loin c'est qu'on était un match
parfait on sert on s'est parlé au début
et on est 6 4 ce serait le fun sera la
fin ensemble dont le travail ensemble
donc des fois si on jouait bon cop bad
cop puis en affaires je le fais souvent
je les fais avec mon associé georges qui
dans les dragons georges karam
c'est mon associée depuis toujours pas
dans toutes les entreprises aujourd'hui
mais au tout début donc on jouait bon
cop bad cop et maryline en ce moment je
joue bon cop bad cop avec gens te
mangerais bon cop bad cop
tout est toujours la bad j'ai pas tout
le temps le ballon souvent le monde il
faut voir françois je sais que maubeuge
gipa pas de brasser moi même j'ai pas le
temps de pâques à perdre en vie puis
j'ai pas part à bord de brasser les gens
mais on a bien joué il ya une fois tant
en taille et je me protège derrière lui
des fois je l'utilisais aussi pu
maîtriser
aussi quand il était un bon match et pas
ou réussir dans big brother faut tu
trouves je regarde les bordels australia
sont toutes deux par deux ok sont tous
deux partout il ya des alliances de 2,2
dans un alliance de 4 dans un alliance
de huit nouveaux toujours que tu crées
des surnomme constamment pour pondre au
travers et gendarmes avaient compris ça
parce qu'ils écoutent aussi son épouse
et moi j'avais compris sable parce que
je les écoute toute la gamme
donc est-ce que j'en commande battre une
deuxième fois
je mets autant qu'ils bon iver
définitivement que serveur n'y a pas de
chance ils peuvent pour ça il faut faire
mais j'ai vraiment besoin de ça mais il
ya besoin de sommeil il ya besoin de
bien manger il ya besoin des choses que
moi je peux pour manger pendant trois
jours je m'en fous je ne peux ne pas
dormait pendant 48 heures je m'en rends
accueillait des choses que lui vont
finir par l'affecter je vais être
capable de vie avec
c'est la seule différence mais qu'elle
fixe est moi j'adorais géante aux
bostonnais me pour la ville est inscrite
parce que tu sais quand tu es rentré le
justement le monde avait une des
préconçue de cette équipe façon abrupte
j'imagine que durant mais fort pour
essayer de déconstruire ce pic d'envois
beaucoup de méfiance mais le ton
gentiment
est ce que tout ça a cliqué ou des buts
et comment il fera sûrement pas possible
non lui avait compris mon idée parce que
moi ma stratégie c'est ok foldingue et
un coup que j'ai gagné ma deuxième
stratégie
j'ai dit à tout le monde moi je veux
rien savoir de gagner puis le monde des
berges et du lit et moi toute façon le
québec va me démolir si je gagne enfin
le rush qui gagne je savais que le
moorish faisait chier le monde
je savais que les gens pensaient que
tango au teint qui vivait dans un
château avec ses majordome qu'il sert et
avec cette mentalité lol et annabelle
fait moi j'ai juste d'un partage gardez
vous avez vu ce capable de gagner
utilisez mois pour aller plus loin ok je
gagnerai pas afin de faire toute ma
bataille afin jeu d'un deuxième
ok c'est vrai je t'ai deuxième parce que
j'avais casting pour ça donc quand ceux
ci que ce casting n'est pas de battre
utilise la ta façon donc encore là
c'était quelque chose de négatif que moi
j'ai utilisées et riche au sun vers la
fin je me sens presque tous face à face
entre bourgogne est bondée rendu justes
noces avec le fait comme
oui non non non c'est pas ça donnerait
si ce travail est fait j'attends
jean-talon avait compris tout de suite
ça faisait partie de ma stratégie le
joueur lui il avait décelé bien dire ok
legault foule
il ya une stratégie donc schmid me colle
à lui qui moi jai vu ke et ils
créeraient jamais de chicane en place
fin qu'on s'y coller un vélo mais ma
stratégie était ce jeu faut que tu
utilises tu regardes ok les gens veulent
pas m'avoir ici comment je peux faire
qui vont être obligés de ma garde est
tout simplement ça doit être un défi
humain si tu mets ton au début on
parlait la différence des bois d'oeuvre
sans occupation double à son double si
toutes sortes de monde différent mais
somme toute de certaines
caractéristiques en commun ainsi une vo2
de loge puis du profil tout différent
brodeur toutes sortes de monde de toutes
sortes de milieux de toutes sortes
d'orge différents ça doit être un
méchant défi de cohabiter
mais au début au début mais regarde ses
mandats les lions parler du bruit ce
club que jamais existé
je sais même pas comment ça se fait que
ces sorties car on est un bon club parce
que après ça il ya eu des questions dont
on veut garder en vie les mines et les
noirs mais non aboutir ce n'est resté
jusqu'à la fin on veut éliminer les gays
dans toutes ces cessa jamais fait partie
de tout rebond n'a jamais discuté de
tout et à la fin moment meilleur allié
fallait que je la sorte parce que tu as
dangereuse takami le mic et 20 ans les
53 ans on avait des belles discussions
on avait beaucoup beaucoup de fun je
laime beaucoup camille mais on avait une
grosse différence
mon meilleur show band en place avec
décroche de keven il ya quand même 30
ans j'en ai 50 3g large à son père pour
le iphone tout le long de l'aventuré
ensemble
il y avait pas d'âge des mines ballon
mais c'est surtout la première nuit tard
yves leterme kinect dans un petit lit à
côté d'eux des gens que tu connais pas
ça ronfle personne dehors
je partage ta douche on avait une seule
douche pour 8 personnes dans notre bar
la plupart des filles dans notre chambre
c'est comme dans chambre des filles non
chercheurs bref dans notre chambre
les gens prenaient leur douche longtemps
qui va prendre sa douche le matin qui va
prendre sa douche le soir ben moi c'est
un beau j'en prends de la balme auction
à melgven mais je te les réchauffeurs de
douche parce que la douche après les
huit minutes avec l'eau chaude à
réchauffer à douche mais il ya cette
partie là de cohabitation apprécié on se
dit bon il ya la partie repos comment
savoir gérer ce que tout le monde veut
facile repos tout seul on va falloir
penser on ne déterminer rapidement qu'on
faisait un repas ensemble jusque un bon
cuisinier
j'allais pas me poser mais je participe
et il m'a donné je me suis comme imposer
offensif est simple j'ai fait wow qui
est des gens qui veulent prendre
l'initiative jambes en trop tu te
retires la pression devient juste le
coupeur de carotte c'est le vivre
ensemble
le vivre ensemble dit ok qu'est ce que
je peux projet faut jamais payante
orgueil dos qui le shabbat rhénane
assiette petit je marche je te garde moi
m'a donné à moi on me demande afin
françois il est un moment donné que deux
sorties de l'année même si jamais me
levais le matin moi j'étais en mode
ok qu'est ce que je veux que celle soir
je le fais d'envié aussi rapidement
qu'est ce que j'ai fait aujourd'hui de
bien qu'est-ce que j'ai fait pas bien
demain qu'un match peut être une
meilleure personne donc c'est tout le
temps ce même questionnement le cas
demain je peux être une meilleure
personne qu'aujourd'hui un meilleur
entrepreneur est ce que j'ai fait du mal
aujourd'hui à des gens sans vous riez
médard maison big brother chaque petit
geste compte fac c'est sûr que tout ça
faisait partie des quelques élèves le
matin dit ouais bof large et par là elle
spectacle qui va gagner le patron cette
semaine mais peut-être la semaine
prochaine donc j'ai du jour pour moi
d'être massé tout le temps sur je
travaillais deux semaines trois semaines
en avances constamment en regardant les
forces pitié des fois ça me faisait rire
il y avait des gens qui faisaient des
alliances puis des grandes stratégies
moi je pense à côté deux autres
n'avaient aucune chance
je vais pourquoi fait des places avec
une chance de gagner leur vie
regardez vos forces là quand même que
ces prophéties vous avez pu même en
écoutant l'émission abrège j'écoutais ça
d'hercule c'est pour faire des
stratégies moi même ma niche parler trop
de stratégie au début que j'ai fait un
mois que je peux plus en parler parce
que si je gagne pas chez cuit au qatar
ne peut pas dire c'est manet cameia dit
hakim votent pas comme deux autres sacs
d'or la semaine d'après et moi j'ai fait
comme yes la chicane et poignante les
deux filles faveur j'avais besoin de
tout ça parce que moi je les travaille
avec kim mais pour séparer kim fallait
que j'attende qui est de la chine dans
son bol y en eut fait qu'un qu' il y
aurait peu chiant avec camille la
bisbille avec lisant un peu fait leur
chantôme aux plumes on aura moins c'est
qu'ils m'ont l'air on l'attendions là
mais comme dans un entonnoir kim pour
l'isoler des filles piquant qui était le
seul pauvre on le ramasse et permettrait
une zone jusqu'à fin mars était toujours
en moi je serai toujours en mode
stratégique permet aux docks et
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour ne pas
être en danger ni cette semaine ni la
semaine d'après lui la semaine l'autre
semaine d'après et je ne sais pas des
thèmes m'a donné de kem annulé jeudi
cure mais je faisais pas ça j'étais en
mode stratégique et mon but était de
rester jusqu'à fin point final donc se
promènent sera-t-il son enveloppe ça
marche et ça fonctionne
planifiez et s'adapter vraiment c'est la
vie mais dans un mode sylvie
entrepreneuriale parce que on est en
compétition 1 contre le mans même tente
et on allie mouche chez des compétiteurs
qui sont mes alliés pas mon niveau je
regrette dans un appel d'offres c'est
qui ça fait partie ça fait partie de
sopi c'est exactement c'est exactement
ce qu'ils gardent kim afin que mais
j'avais il y avait trop version de kim
kim qui gagnait qui est un peu arrogant
keim qui perdait qui est à terre et kim
que besoin de demander qui est pas
capable donc la dernière semaine
elle avait besoin de me convaincre de
l'emmener en finale si je gagnais la
deuxième épreuve et elle me dit françois
ça prend une femme en finale et je dois
gagner big brother in stream c'est parce
que je teins go et c'est moi qui va
t'amener tu me demandes de tam n'est pas
c'est une fille parce que tu dois gagner
border les choses que je t'amène sont
nuls et non mais c'est la rumeur était
possible ton argument n'est pas bon
parce que si tu veux que je t'amène
falloir que tu met sur un piédestal
brega françois bat ok tu sais que tu vas
me bat en finale emmène moi c'était ce
sont je cale le pot fait don de ma
décision était prise quand même de ne
pas l'amener parce que son père avait
été mauvais [ __ ] sa chatte à petit on
pitch de vente appartenant à la personne
c'est la même chose en affaires il ya
des moment donné tu vas parler un
banquier le ministre parle un client
négatif en un client lui venait d'avoir
son argent le banc qui lui veut savoir
c'est quoi tes marge ses voeux le savoir
ta bouteille d'eau lors qu'ils coûtent
200 av à combien trois pièces parfait il
est grand temps de marge de 3000 pour ça
le client le troupeau des échanges à
3000% bonne bouteille de vin qui lui
veut pas le savoir weaver
sa bouteille d'eau il veut sa bouteille
d'eau qui passe qui a payé des 4 coûte
2,99 tabac trois pierres ses fins bride
amis donc tu vois le pitch fonctions
adaptées en conséquence dans la vraie
vie de walbach qui tu vois ta péter
braid fait péter les bretelles de tde
des marges pas de man clients des
banques clientes enfin pas de marge
est-ce que avant contre laisse partir on
peut savoir un scoop d'un produit qui
s'en vient sur eux
françois lambert points - oui réseau sur
lequel du travail qui est pas sortie
n'est pas encore oui mais qu'at t bonds
web et y entendrait travailler sur ça
c'est toujours le sortir des sentiers
battus donc le pop corn à l'érable plus
rien n'avait pas c'est tout le temps du
pop rock avec on a travaillé fort après
six mois ça a l'air simple de recherche
développement b de recherche et de
montrer ses coups de pied dans machine
par le fameux recherche les crises ont
écouté d'un macho et parce que
j'essayais fin du pape en arabe ou tel
boycott n'était pas bon trop salée pas
assez salée
ça a duré six mois à tout les jours on
achetait département de paiement déjà
mon frère hassen mouche plus capable
c'est ça marche pas puis j'étais sous
bar d'être découragé paix d'utiliser
comme tout le monde sirop de maïs
demandent année on a travaillé avec du
sirop plus claire tout bon ça a pris
longtemps on a réussi métier elle au
québec les gens achètent des cannes de
sirop dans le dos qu'on a décidé de
faire céder et moi mais c'est con parce
qu'on n'utilise que un peu la pression
la main dans le frigidaire puissions ne
met pas dans un pot de plastique bien
menée au chu la rouille tu veux tu peux
pas nier de maladie donc foutage est
vrai qu'on est en train de travailler
sur un nouvel emballage on va le vendre
en paca this c'est les petites canettes
comme des v8 utilisation pour deux
personnes à matane donc ça on va savoir
si je sais que ça va marcher mais à date
tout ce qu'on a fait de révolutionner
peu la façon de faire du sirop d'érable
donc l'on s'en vient pilote l'utiliser
mais assez pour deux personnes donc le
matin on assume que pt2 moquer de
pression mais on va le vendre un paquet
de six comme des canettes de vie huit
enfants est-ce que ça va fonctionner
je pense que oui mais je le sais pas ça
fonctionne pas bon les paniers avec
25000 canettes qu'on va jeter aux
poubelles éventuellement mais à date
tout ce qu'on fait fini par fonctionner
comme le gab
on s'envoie versant différentes
chandelle on s'en vient avec du savon de
brebis une centaine de salons de brebis
mais c'est toujours utile aux autres
notre philosophie on est parti de
l'érable et rabin c'est l'érable pour
moi là c'est mon wayne gretzky c'est mon
conomique des voeux de onekey ces
masters exactement c'est ma vedette dans
mon art dans mon entreprise
ma côtés de la vedette le paquet
d'autres produits et ses soins
d'entreprise de ton produit phare qu'on
est en train de lancer donc l'érable de
rester au centre mais
le senior à travailler chandelle le lait
de brebis parce que j'élève vraiment des
moutons pauvres et lorsqu'on lui dit de
faire des chants des savons six mois je
vais utiliser le brebis donc c'est ce
qu'on a fait mais c'est sur les petites
canettes je pense qu'on va révolutionner
la façon de consommer le sirop d'érable
avec des plus petits formats ou les
acheter la fameuse canne qui est là
depuis 1950
elle est du port est changé cela
justement un petit ajustement puis que
ce soit 4 fini d'un dépôt panier avec un
sirop qui dans le frigidaire pendant des
mois et des mois des mots je pense qu'on
peut faire quelque chose de bien avec ça
on va voir merci beaucoup
françois cau merci d'avoir écouté ce
podcast jusqu'à la fin de ce pas que
vous avez apprécié la conversation ça
prouve que vous êtes de réelles fans de
conversation et sans fil pas de casser
on vous remercie vraiment beaucoup
si vous voulez voir plus de contenus
plus de conversation c'est sûr
pétillante que ça se passe il ya surper
tués a non seulement on met tous les
podcasts en ligne au moment où est ce qu
on les tourne donc on a beaucoup de
semaine d'avant sur le pétrole mais on
fait aussi des encore moins de filtres
qui sont exclusifs au monde pictural où
est ce que on parle d'homme nicole et
moi de la conversation combien d'abord
parce qu'on met un peu plus en
profondeur dans certains sujets qu'on
voulait aborder ou qu'on a abordé
pendant le podcast donc allez sur une
page de turenne les le lien vers savoir
dans la description du podcast qui
remercie encore une fois nous avons
écouté jusqu'à la fonte